[Musique]
Jésabelle Coupé Souson. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bonne
année.
Bonne heureuse année à vous aussi et
puis à ceux à ceux et celles qui nous
écoutent. Donc je suis Jésabelle Coupé
Souberan. Je suis maîtresse de
conférence à l'université Parisien
Panéon Sorbon et puis je travaille
également pour un SIN tank qui s'appelle
l'Institut VBL qui travaille sur la
transition écologique sur les sur les
réformes à promouvoir pour avancer dans
la transition. Il y a du boulot. Voilà.
du courage
et du courage. Il faut Ouais ouais, il
faut du boulot et du courage
effectivement pour avancer dans la
transition écologique et on en manque
donc on
pas l'institut VBL mais ailleurs on en
manque pas mal j'ai l'impression. Donc
on a décidé de vous faire venir et de
faire notre rentrée avec vous et de
parler économie parce que on a besoin de
vos lumières, on a besoin de de
comprendre ce qui se passe à travers
votre regard, à travers votre façon de
penser, à travers vos l'arborescence de
votre pensée. Donc on va un peu vous
cuisiner histoire de de savoir comment
vous percevez les choses. Première
question, comment vous percevez le
gouvernement français par rapport à la
gestion de la crise Covid, la gestion de
la crise de la guerre, la gestion de la
crise de la dette, la gestion de la
crise des matières premières en
difficulté, du mois de la pénurie des
matières premières et comment vous voyez
en fait la la gestion du gouvernement
par rapport à l'énergie et ensuite
selon vous, est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est viable les rustines de les
rustines budgétaires pour sauver les
entreprises prise à gauche comme à
droite et après je vous poserai de tr
deux trois autres questions. Je vous en
prie.
D'accord. Bon, je pense qu'on on vit
on vit dans un pays qui s'abîme. Euh
on vit dans un pays qui s'abîme où on
prend sans doute pas suffisamment soin
de ceux qui de ceux qui souffrent, des
plus modestes où on est plutôt gentil
avec ceux qui vont bien et puis où on
prend pas suffisamment soin de ceux qui
en ont besoin. Je pense qu'on est
pourtant dans un
dans un beau pays a priori où on est
doté d'une d'une assez bonne protection
sociale
mais
bon qui est en train de qui est en train
de s'abîmer considérablement. En fait,
je crois qu'on est euh on est on est
gouverné par euh ce qu'on appelle le
néolibéralisme. Et le néolibéralisme
aujourd'hui, c'est pas c'est pas tant un
recul de l'État, c'est plutôt l'État qui
se qui est mis au service euh non pas de
ceux qui en ont besoin justement hein,
mais de euh au service des euh au
service des marchés, au service des au
service des entreprises. Je pense qu'on
n'est pas suffisamment résolu à
transformer la à transformer la société.
On n'est pas suffisamment résolu à
avancer dans une transformation
écologique qui soit qui soit juste. On
se donne pas les moyens de ça. Après
bon, c'est pas c'est pas qu' un problème
français, hein. Je pense que cette cette
absence de bifurcation,
on la constate,
on la constate un peu partout
malheureusement. On la constate en
Europe, on la constate dans le dans le
monde entier. C'est-à-dire qu'on reste
on reste enfermé dans euh euh on reste
enfermé dans le dans le monde d'hier. On
s'interroge pas suffisamment sur nos sur
nos modes de production, sur nos modes
de consommation euh qui euh qui nous
mène qui nous mènent en fait droit dans
le droit dans le mur. Donc on a besoin
de ces on a besoin de ces
transformations là et je pense qu'on se
dote pas des on se dote pas des moyens
on se dote pas des moyens suffisants et
et le gouvernement dans tout ça le
gouvernement je vous donne un exemple
gouvernement néolibéral si je parle
selon votre contrôle
il éponge avec de l'argent public 40 %
de la facture électrique de certaines
entreprises h
euh il propose le report du paiement de
des impôts, des cotisations.
Mais pourquoi on laisse pas faire le le
marché tuer ses entreprises puis ensuite
revenir tel un phnix ? Pourquoi l'État
ne laisse pas ça
en place ? Pourtant c'est un état
néolibéral, il devrait laisser faire.
Non, mais justement en fait l'état
l'état l'état néolibéral c'est pas
forcément si vous voulez un un état qui
laisse faire et qui croit dur comme
faire en la capacité d'autorégulation du
marché hein. C'est plutôt un état qui
vient qui vient au secours du marché
quand il en a besoin. Euh et c'est ce
qui s'est passé au fond pendant euh à la
fois si vous voulez pendant la crise
financière euh pendant la pendant la
crise sanitaire. Alors, pendant la crise
financière de 2007 euh 2008 euh puis
plus encore pendant la la la crise
sanitaire, l'État a été a été très
présent mais précisément pour venir euh
pour venir aider le pour venir aider le
marché. Alors, c'est plus vrai
d'ailleurs pendant le je dirais pendant
la crise sanitaire que pendant la crise
financière. Pendant la crise financière
euh la gestion de crise, elle a
grandement reposé en fait. Alors, au
niveau européen comme dans d'autres euh
comme dans d'autres zones et dans
d'autres dans d'autres pays, mais pour
ce qui nous intéresse au niveau
européen, la crise financière a
largement reposé en fait sur la banque
centrale et donc sur la politique
monétaire. Euh et ça c'est quelque chose
de
bon, c'est quelque chose d'assez euh
d'assez intrigant si vous voulez.
C'est-à-dire que les banques centrales
qui ont euh qui ont largement
euh finalement contribuer à euh à cette
crise financière parce qu'elles ont mené
euh une politique monétaire euh qui euh
qui était très accommodante dans les
années dans les années 2000. et bien ont
été ensuite les institutions euh qui euh
euh ont été amenées à gérer euh cette
crise financière et qui l'ont géré euh
en fait, si vous voulez en euh en
facilitant euh grandement le
refinancement des banques, ensuite en
achetant des masses euh de des masses de
titres sur les marchés financiers et
donc en en mettant en faisant déborder
en fait la liquidité sur les marchés
financiers et probablement en préparant
en fait les crises d'après en achetant
des actifs pourris.
Alors, en achetant des actifs pourris,
on peut le dire autrement. C'est-à-dire
que en fait quand les banques centrales
interviennent pour gérer des crises
financières, euh ce qu'elles font d'une
part, c'est qu'elles mettent beaucoup de
liquidité à la disposition des banques
en espérant que les banques mettront
elles-mêmes la liquidité nécessaire à la
disposition de l'économie, ce qu'elles
font pas nécessairement. Et ce qu'elles
font aussi, c'est que euh elles
rachètent les titres dont plus personne
ne veut sur les marchés puis elles
essaient de de retirer du marché euh les
titres pourris comme vous dites, ceux
dont plus personne ne veut pour essayer
de remettre éventuellement ce quand
elles le peuvent euh les titres de
meilleure de meilleure qualité. Et donc
cette crise financière de 2007-2008,
elle a reposé sur une politique
monétaire euh extrêmement accommodante,
d'accord ? Donc de
liquidité mise à la disposition des
banques et des marchés. elle a un peu
moins reposé euh sur euh sur la
politique budgétaire, c'est-à-dire sur
l'aide au ménage, sur l'aide aux
entreprises par les États, en tout cas
en Europe. qu'en Europe, on est resté
quand même assez coincé dans une dans
une rigueur dans une relative rigueur
budgétaire pendant la gestion de de
crise financière et après on s'est plus
largement émancipé en fait de cette
rigueur budgétaire pendant la gestion de
crise euh sanitaire. Toute la question
aujourd'hui euh c'est au fond la
question de savoir si euh on va être
capable justement de euh de mener une
bonne combinaison de de politique
économique pour gérer la situation
macroconjoncturelle actuelle. On est euh
dans une situation où euh l'inflation a
considérablement euh remonté. Ça a été
euh
Non, elle a pas considérablement
remonté.
Alors si enfin si si l'inflation
Bruno Lemire a dit que non.
Ah bon ? Bruno Ouais. Alors oui, Bruno
Lemer nous dit que les choses sont sous
contrôle et que euh l'inquer
et que qu'il ne faut pas paniquer, que
l'inflation va euh va regagner la la
cible visée par euh par la Banque
centrale européenne
et ce sera le cas.
Alors, on sait pas si ce sera le cas
parce que euh
avec une grosse récession,
Ouais. On sait pas véritablement, si
vous voulez si euh cette inflation sera
sous contrôle. Déjà, ce qu'il faut dire,
c'est que euh cette inflation, on ne l'a
pas forcément euh vu venir. D'accord.
Alors, on l'a pas vu venir, mais je
dirais même les euh euh même la
Faites pas du Macron ce soir, s'il vous
plaît.
Non, non, non. On l'a pas vu venir, mais
même les euh même la plupart des
économistes ne l'ont pas vu venir.
Alors,
la plupart des économistes ne servent à
rien en fait.
Ouais. Si de temps en temps, on
Vous vous en connaissez beaucoup des
économistes ?
Comment
vous en connaissez beaucoup des
économistes ?
Bah, j'en fais j'en j'en fais partie.
Vous êtes à part Ouais. Euh, j'essaie de
Ils sont chefs d'entreprise les les
économistes ?
Non, ils sont pas chefs d'entreprise les
économist il ils investissent selon leur
bons précept sur les marchés financiers
les économistes que vous connaissez.
Ah, ça j'en sais rien. Il y a peut-être
des économistes financiers qui
appliquent leur bon leur bons précept.
Mais quand ils ont les sa quand les deux
quand les les économistes financiers
justement ont cette ont cette casquette
de euh en cette casquette de financier
praticien, ça peut être un petit peu
problématique aussi hein parce que les
délit d'initiés pourquoi ?
Bah en fait ça vous rend un peu ça vous
rend un peu jugé parti après. C'estd que
c'est pas si mal au fond d'avoir euh je
dirais d'avoir un peu de d'avoir un peu
de de recul. D'accord. Et quand euh
quand vous analysez quand vous analysez
l'organisation des entreprises, euh je
pense que c'est euh finalement c'est pas
si mal de prendre un petit peu de recul
et pas forcément et de pas forcément
être chef d'entreprise. Quand vous
analysez le fonctionnement ou le
dysfonctionnement du système financier,
bah c'est pas si mal de pas de pas
travailler si vous voulez dans un dans
un fond dans un fond d'investissement.
Euh donc bon, je sais pas, je pense que
c'est pas mal d'avoir son euh d'avoir un
peu de recul, d'avoir son indépendance
d'esprit. Après, il faut pas s'enfermer
dans sa tour d'ivoire et puis il faut il
faut être en dialogue bien sûr avec ceux
qui sont sur le sur le terrain, mais
maintenir un peu de distance, un peu de
recul, avoir cette vision un peu
systémique euh je pense que c'est euh je
pense que c'est utile
et et euh quand on a des économistes qui
nous donnent des grandes théories
mais qui ne voi pas les crises
financières arriver, qui ne voit pas
l'inflation arriver, qui
en gros en gros
Ils font beaucoup de bruit avec leur
bouche avant
pendant ils ont tout déjà tout anticipé
mais après c'est toujours le même
bordel.
Ouais. Alors effectivement, beaucoup
d'économistes ont pas vu la crise
financière arriver en en 2007-2008 parce
que
euh je pense que beaucoup négligait le
euh le la recrudescence de l'instabilité
financière qui est allée de paire avec
le développement des marchés de capitaux
à partir des années 80 90 2000.
Beaucoup peut-être se sont enfermés dans
l'idée que euh les marchés désormais
avaient considérablement gagné en
efficience, était capable de de
s'autoréguler. Bon, je pense que la
crise financière, on a quand même
réveillé euh quelques-uns. Pour autant,
on est encore pas mal enfermé, je
dirais, dans dans
le dogme du marché, dans l'idée que tout
peut passer par le marché, dans l'idée
que les marchés financiers ont un peu
d'inefficience. Mais souvent et c'est
vrai aussi ça pas seulement pour les
économistes d'ailleurs, mais pour pas
mal de nos je dirais pour le pour les
autorités de pour les les autorités de
de supervision de régulation pour les
banques centrales. Les
je pense qu'ils admettent aujourd'hui le
fait que il y a de l'inefficience sur
les marchés mais pour eux cette
inefficience c'est au fond simplement
une une inefficience on va dire
informationnelle. C'est-à-dire que les
euh les marchés ne véhiculent pas toute
l'information dont on a besoin. Et donc
au fond, il suffirait de euh d'obliger
les acteurs du marché à communiquer
davantage d'informations et après cela
et bien les prix de marché seront de
meilleurs de meilleurs signaux, de
meilleurs de meilleurs vecteurs. On
pourra se reposer sur ces prix de marché
pour prendre les bonnes décisions. Bon
en fait euh
je peux vous couper ?
Ouais bien sûr.
J'allais dire un autre truc important
mais truc important
le en fait l'inefficience des marchés
c'est aussi une inefficience en terme de
d'allocation des ressources. C'est pas
simplement une inefficience en terme
d'information et ça c'est très vrai pour
les marchés financiers. On on le voit
bien en fait, les marchés financiers ne
permettent pas de bien allouer en fait
les ressources les ressources
financières. Aujourd'hui, les ressources
financières ne vont pas ne vont pas au
bon endroit. Elles vont beaucoup euh
dans euh encore dans le financement,
dans dans ce qui rapporte, hein, bien
entendu, parce que c'est le principe.
Euh elles vont beaucoup dans les
énergies euh dans le financement des
énergies des énergies fossiles.
ça dans dans des activités extractives
qui polluent mais ça y va parce que ça
rapporte et ça ne ça ne va pas là où on
aurait besoin que ça aille dans des
activités dans des activités compatibles
avec euh avec le respect des limites
planétaires, avec le respect de de
l'humanité. Mais vous voyez qu'en fait
en euh on sort d'une logique marchande
quand euh quand on veut que les
ressources aillent à cet endroit. Ce qui
veut dire que
c'est pour ça que vous travaillez pas
dans le privé.
Euh c'est pour ça que je travaille pas
C'est je suis pas je suis pas non plus
si vous voulez je suis pas une
antimarchée mais je
je me dis que bah le marché c'est bien
pour coordonner des activités des
activités marchandes, des activités
rentables. Euh aujourd'hui, on a besoin
d'allouer des ressources vers euh plein
de choses qui coûtent beaucoup et qui
rapportent pas beaucoup. C'est qu'on a
besoin de réaliser des masses
d'investissements pour transformer nos
sociétés. Euh des masses euh des masses
d'investissement euh alors dans la
transformation écologique, dans la
transformation.
Taille, quelle taille ?
Bah alors, on a
c'est le PIB des États-Unis, c'est le
PIB du monde entier. C'est c'est quoi ?
On parle de quoi ? On parle de 10
balles, on parle on parle de centaines
de milliards de milliards. Il commence à
y avoir
pas mal d'évaluations si vous voulez des
investissements des investissements
nécessaires
d'évaluation c'estàd lors de la dernière
d'estimation
d'estimation c'estàd lors de la dernière
réunionité aigue de ce censé
non il y a pas mal de
il y a eu il y a eu un petit peu de
wishful thinking et puis pour faire bien
auprès de sa chaîne hiérarchique on a
dit on a plein d'idées les gars vous
inquiétez pas il faut réallouer les
masses monétair
non mais il y a il y a quand même si
vous voulez un certain nombre de
de d'institut de de centre d'études qui
travaillent qui essayent d'évaluer les
les de chercheur ou c'est ça qui parfois
trouvent des choses intéressantes et
parfois pas. Mais
il y a un institut pour le climat qui
s'appelle l'institut forcy qui réalise
chaque année un panorama des
investissements nécessaires pour
réaliser cette transformation
écologique. Ils sont ils le
reconnaissent eux-mêmes assez
conservateurs, assez prudents en fait
dans leur dans leur dans leurs
évaluations. Alors eux par exemple
arrivent
à
à un chiffre de l'ordre de 20 30
milliards qui serait nécessaire dans un
pays comme la France chaque année 20 30
milliards supplémentaires
d'investissement nécessaires dans la
transition écologique dans un pays comme
la France pendant 10 années. Il y a
d'autres évaluations qui vont qui sont
un peu au-delà de ça qui sont plutôt de
l'ordre de 3 4 5 % du produit intérieur
brut dans des pays comme la France, dans
les pays européens
pour réaliser ces transformations là.
Euh toute la question en fait, c'est de
savoir si euh on va pouvoir réaliser
tous les investissements nécessaires
simplement en réalloinant euh les euh
euh les euh les financements euh les
financements actuels euh ou bien euh si
on va avoir besoin de repenser le de
repenser le financement. Moi, je fais
partie des des économistes qui pensent
que on a besoin en fait de repenser le
financement de nos économies si on veut
pouvoir réaliser ces dépenses là.
Couper.
Ouais. Bien sûr,
on reparlera de l'efficience et
l'efficience des marchés tout de suite
après. Mais le
je vous coupe sur un bout de phrase qui
m'intéresse beaucoup, c'est "On a besoin
de repenser."
H
Mais repenser, il faut il faut le
vouloir.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous pensez que
l'économie veut réellement
changer ? Et derrière l'économie, est-ce
que vous pensez que les gens, la
population, la pleb, appelez ça comme
vous voulez, les gens comme nous
veulent vraiment ça ? Est-ce que est-ce
qu'il faut pas attendre ou est-ce qu'il
on va pas être obligé d'attendre encore
une génération pour qu'il y ait ce
changement de paradigme dans les
perceptions de faire des bouches en
canard avec un un téléphone qui vaut
2000 balles
posté à l'autre bout du monde ? Est-ce
que c'est bien, c'est pas bien ? Est-ce
qu' Est-ce qu'il faut pas une
administration de la perception des
choses autres que bah les bébés Fox sont
en train de mourir, vous rendez pas
compte ? C'est triste,
le le réchauffement climatique va faire
bouger des millions de personnes. Vous
vous rendez pas compte ? C'est triste,
vous rendez pas compte, est-ce qu'il
faut pas une bonne dictature verte sur
les marchés financiers ? Je pousse le
raisonnement à l'extrême.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas maintenant arrêter
les bêtises de dire voilà le marché, la
main visible du marché va nous sauver ?
Alors que c'est pas vrai. Les marchés
sont administrés comme dans un état
communiste. C'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai
?
Ils sont sous perfusion en tout cas. Là
là on en sort là on est en train de la
débrancher la perfusion c'est qu'il y en
a plus dans la perfusion. C'est
ce qui va peut-être c'est le remettre la
réalité dans l'assiette. C'est ça.
Donc les marchés financiers sont
administrés comme dans une exion
soviétique. Euh ils ont mis des gardes
de fou à l'hyperfquency trading avec dès
que ça commence à sauter un peu trop
fort parce qu'il y a des copains qui
s'amusent ou des puissances étrangères
qui s'amusent. Hop, on arrête tout. Tout
va bien.
C'est normal. Donc est-ce que vous
pensez pas et puis sans vous sans parler
de la manipulation de certains cours de
marché, rappelez-vous le ribor ? Le
ribord ? H
vous vous rappelez de ce petit scandal ?
C'est c'est c'était c'était propre hein.
Hérois s'en rappelle très bien
d'ailleurs.
Et et donc on se retrouve avec un
changement de paradigme qui est
nécessaire pour la survie sur terre h
à plus de 30 ou 40 ans.
Des marchés financiers qui commencent à
réaliser que bah ça va être compliqué et
là tout va bien. La question que je vous
pose, c'est est-ce que vous sentez une
autre crise financière arrivée tellement
forte qu'on aura beau avoir des
politiques qui agitent les bras et qui
bouge très vite leur bouche pour nous
donner de la rhthorique et de
l'éloquence à gogo, est-ce que ça va
peut-être pas suffire ce coup-là ?
Est-ce qu'on va se retrouver avec une
stacflation dramatique ? Est-ce qu'on va
se retrouver avec des pénuries sur les
matières premières qui vont être
dramatiques ? Je parle matière première
énergétique nécessaire à la
réindustrialisation de la France, au
green washing, à ce que vous voulez.
Est-ce que vous sentez un truc venir là
? Genre un truc bien fort ?
Alors, il y a 10000 questions dans votre
question là, hein, si je puis me
permettre. C'est c'est laquelle la
meilleure ? Laquelle la meilleure pour
vous ?
D'accord. Euh, vous m'interrogiez sur au
fond sur le
sur notre sur la possibilité de
changement, sur la perception du
changement. Est-ce que c'est pas du wish
full sinking d'une bande de IP
économiste qui sont en train de se dire
"Bon, on vient de se réveiller les gars.
Là, on est en train de voir que dans
tous les scénarios, on a les couleurs à
l'écarlate.
C'est pas une fessée qu'on va se
prendre, c'est vraiment une
bonne tabassade et on risque de pas s'en
remettre.
Ouais, je pense qu'il y a une prise de
conscience quand même du une prise de
conscience croissante du changement
nécessaire. Euh pour autant, je crois
que on n'est pas encore doté euh des
instruments permettants de réaliser ce
changement. Et alors deux choses euh
je pense qu'au niveau euh de la prise de
conscience, on a progressé avec les
crises mais manifestement elles n'ont
pas été suffisamment fortes. C'està-dire
que
c'est progressante, c'est ça ? Bah en
fait
euh quand il y a eu la crise financière
en 2007-2008,
on a
euh on a pris conscience de
l'hyperfinanciarisation
de des dérives de la finance et pour
autant et bien on n'est pas parvenu à
les corriger. On a certes entrepris des
réformes mais qui n'ont pas été
suffisantes, qui ne sont pas allé
jusqu'au bout, qui ont en effet été
bloqué en grande partie par
euh euh
par le secteur bancaire et financier
lui-même, par le lobby par le lobby
financier qui qui est parvenu à
à entraver en fait hein le à entraver la
conduite de ces réformes à
ce n'est pas entravé
pas.
Bon, ça c'était pour c'était pour la
c'était pour la crise c'était pour la
crise financière. Donc, on se on avait
une fenêtre d'opportunité qui s'est
finalement assez vite refermée avec la
crise sanitaire. Euh je crois que
on peut commencer si vous voulez quand
même sérieusement à faire le lien en
avec la crise écologique. C'est-à-dire
que cette crise sanitaire, c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose qui tombe du
ciel. Euh c'est euh
une crise euh en partie euh liée à au
dérèglements euh aux dérèglements
écologiques environnementaux euh euh au
déclin de nos écosystèmes. Donc on a euh
on a une crise qui est liée à ça et ça
aurait dû nous amener à véritablement
réaliser la nécessité de la
transformation écologique. La prise de
conscience progresse mais elle n'est pas
suffisante. Il faut sans doute, il
faudra sans doute des crises encore plus
fortes ou des manifestations encore plus
forte de la crise écologique parce que
cette crise écologique, elle est là. On
commence on commence à la vivre. C'est
pas quelque chose qui
euh qui se présente à un horizon futur.
Très souvent, si vous voulez, on pas
très souvent, on a parler de la tragédie
des horizons. C'est d'ailleurs un
financier qui qui évoquait cette
tragédie des horizons, Marc Carnet. Ça a
eu du bon hein d'ailleurs parce que ça
quelque part ça a éveillé un peu la
conscience des financiers. Mais
c'est beau, c'est beau.
Oui, c'est beau. C'est poétique. Mais en
semblant dire, si vous voulez qu'il y a
une forme de de euh d'incompatibilité,
donc de tragédie entre l'horizon
l'horizon courttermiste des marchés,
même des des gouvernants, des des
décideurs des décideurs euh publics et
puis euh l'horizon long euh auquel se
manifesterait les dommages euh euh les
dommages environnementaux. Bon, en
réalité, c'est plus sur un horizon long,
c'est là. D'accord. Euh donc, on n'est
même plus, si vous voulez, dans cette
dans cette tragédie des horizons. On est
confronté aujourd'hui à la crise
écologique. Euh pour autant euh
et financière
et financière. Alors euh on est sorti
enfin pas tout à fait d'ailleurs de la
crise financière de 2007-2008 mais là si
vous voulez on n pas je pense qu'à
l'issue de cette crise financière de
20078 on n pas véritablement remédié en
profondeur hein au dysfonctionnement du
au dysfonctionnement du système
financier
la gestion de crise financière a
continué en fait de d'alimenter
l'hypertrophie du système financier
d'alimenter d'alimenter la
Est-ce que je peux vous demander de
préciser un petit peu
la gestion de la crise financière ? Vous
pouvez me préciser ça ? Vous faites
référence au prix de la banque de Suède
auprès de Ben Bern. C'est ça.
Alors euh
pourquoi ça vous fait marrer parce que
c'est c une boutade entre les lignes,
entre économistes. C'est ça
ouais. La gestion de crise financière,
c'est ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure,
hein. c'est-à-dire le la façon dont les
les banques centrales sont intervenues
pour pour gérer la crise en en abruvant
les banques et les marchés de de
liquidité par des des prêts aux banques
à taux à taux nul voire même voire même
à taux négatif sous certaines sous
certaines conditions avec des avec des
rachats de de titres massifs. Ça été ça
la crise, ça était ça la gestion de
crise financière. Mais à chaque fois, la
gestion de crise financière façon
boomer.
Façon façon boomer. Ouais. C'est-à-dire
une euh
tout pour les vieux
en fait, une gestion de crise financière
où euh on essaie de réparer les dégâts
après coup euh où on les répare jamais
vraiment où on prépare vraisemblablement
vraisemblablement celle d'après. Parce
que voyez en fait en en alimentant
autant les marchés en liquidité et bien
les banques centrales ont contribué à la
formation de nouvelles bulles sur les
marchés sur les marchés financiers.
Expliquez différemment ça donne quoi ?
Alors, une bulle euh sur un marché,
c'est euh en fait un emballement euh des
euh un emballement des prix d'actifs,
une augmentation continue et qui euh qui
s'autoalimente euh des euh des prix
d'actifs.
Euh quand on définit ça euh un peu dans
le dans le jargon dans le jargon
financiers, on parle d'une euh on parle
d'une déconnexion croissante entre euh
les prix de marché et entre la valeur de
marché d'un d'un actif, d'une action par
exemple, mais ça peut être un autre type
de d'actif. Ça marche aussi bien sûr
pour les actifs immobiliers entre la
valeur de marché de cet actif et puis sa
valeur fondamentale. Alors la valeur
fondamentale d'un actif au fond, on sait
jamais trop ce que c'est. D'accord ?
Pour une action par exemple, c'est ce
que va rapporter en fait cette action
dans le futur. Bon euh c'est jamais très
facile à déterminer ça cette valeur
fondamentale. Alors comme c'est jamais
très facile à déterminer, on met
toujours un peu en doute, si vous voulez
l'écart qui peut y avoir entre euh le
prix de marché, la valeur de marché et
la valeur fondamentale. En cela étant,
quand on voit, si vous voulez les
marchés continuer de s'emballer,
continuer de de progresser pendant des
années après la crise financière alors
que l'économie réelle, elle peine à se
relever, bon, on se dit qu'il y a quand
même une déconnexion effectivement entre
des valeurs de marché et puis des
valeurs des valeurs fondamentales
réelles. vraisemblablement et bien à la
fois la gestion de crise financière puis
la gestion de crise sanitaire qui s'est
faite sur le même mode à alimenter
ces bulles. Et aujourd'hui et bien on
est on est passé à une configuration
assez différente où en fait on n'est
plus si vous voulez
on n'est plus dans une zone d'inflation
d'inflation très très basse. on est au
contraire et bien dans une dans une zone
où l'inflation remonte et où les banques
centrales vont peut-être pas pouvoir
faire grand-chose en fait contre cette
contre cette inflation. On va peut-être
pouvoir en rediscuter, mais elles font
comme si en tout cas elles comme si
elles pouvait agir contre cette
inflation. Donc que font-elles ? et bien
elles remontent leur taux d'intérêt
c'estd qu'elles se montrent un peu moins
généreuses
envers les envers les banque elles
arrêtent d'acheter des titres sur les
marchés et bah se faisant en arrêtant
d'acheter des titres sur les marchés ça
alimente l'augmentation des taux
des taux des march des des taux longs
sur les marchés c'est des taux des des
titres de notamment des titres des
titres souverains sur les marchés ça
le quand ces taux remontent et cette
remontée des taux et bien
ça peut ça peut faire éclater ça peut
faire éclater les bulles sur les bulles
qui se sont formées sur les marchés sur
les marchés financiers ça peut aussi la
soutenabilité de la dette.
Alors oui, ça peut bien sûr que ça peut
compromettre la soutenabilité de la
dette. Et c'est pour ça si vous voulez
que quand finalement les États sont
obligés de se financer sur les marchés,
et bien
ils sont finalement contraints de
ils sont ils sont ils sont contraints de
rendre leur dette
soutenable, en tout cas de la conformer
au souhaits du marché. Et ça c'est tout
à fait incompatible avec ensuite et bien
les le financement des investissements
dont on a besoin. On a besoin de
beaucoup d'investissement public pour
réaliser la transformation. Les États
sont obligés de rendre aussi leur dett
sexy auprès des marchés
en disant vous inquiétez pas
on est la France on rembourse un
lanister rembourse toujours ses dettes.
Donc il il la rendent un peu sexy. Puis
des fois des fois les marchés ils aiment
pas trop. Donc pour la rendre un peu
plus sexy, ils la font à tout variable.
Ouais. Alors effectivement, si vous
voulez, les États se soumettent
se soumettent à la pression hein, à la
pression des marchés, aux exigences des
marchés dès lors que c'est leur seul
mode de c'est leur seul mode de
financement. Et donc ils se soumettent
aux exigences des investisseurs. Quand
l'inflation remonte, bah oui, c'est
plutôt pas mal euh de proposer des
titres de dette indexés euh sur
l'inflation, ce qui ensuite coûte très
cher et ce qui ensuite et bien euh se
euh se se traduit par un étren
comment
Jésabelle, vous n'écoutez rien du tout.
Pourquoi ?
Bruno Leire a dit que l'inflation, elle
est baissée.
Donc c'est vachement bien.
On est pas bien là en 2023. Ouais, mais
bon la euh si vous voulez le la méthode
coué, c'est important hein, les banques
centrales euh les banques centrales la
pratiquent euh la pratique aussi
beaucoup. C'est-à-dire que euh
l'inflation dépend largement euh des
anticipations que euh l'on forme à
propos de l'inflation et notamment des
anticipations des investisseurs à propos
de l'inflation. Alors si si Christine la
garde et puis euh si si Bruno Lemire et
tous les autres ministres des des
finances dans la zone euro arrive à
convaincre les marchés que l'inflation
va se résorber, peut-être qu'ils
arriveront à à agir un petit peu sur les
anticipations et peut-être qu'en effet
ils arriveront à faire refluer un peu
l'inflation. Mais il y a pas, si vous
voulez que
il y a pas que cette partie euh il y a
pas que cette partie autoréalisatrice,
je dirais, dans dans l'inflation. Il y a
pas que cette il y a pas que cette part
d'anticipation dans les déterminants
dans les déterminants de l'inflation. Il
y a aussi vraisemblablement dans
l'inflation actuelle une part beaucoup
plus structurelle. Et ce qu'il ce qui va
advenir de l'inflation dans les euh dans
les mois à venir, dans les années euh à
venir euh euh dépend en fait de cette
part euh de cette part structurelle. Euh
je crois que l'inflation actuelle,
ce n'est pas qu'un problème euh
conjoncturel. Euh il y a euh euh à
l'origine de cette inflation, il y a
bien sûr des problèmes euh des problèmes
de désorganisation de l'offre euh du
fait des des conséquences hein de la
crise sanitaire, des problèmes qui ont
été largement accentués par euh par la
guerre en Ukraine. Donc ça c'est une
partie de l'explication d'inflation. Il
y a peut-être une petite partie aussi de
l'inflation qui vient du fait que
pendant la crise sanitaire et bien la
demande a été soutenue. Mais ça, je
crois que c'est plus vrai aux États-Unis
en fait que dans la zone euro parce que
le quoi qu'il en coûte euh dans le quoi
qu'il en coûte en France euh euh
notamment et dans un certain nombre de
pays de la zone euro a a plus
soutenu l'offre que
que la demande. C'est pas vrai pour tous
les pays. En Allemagne, par exemple, la
demande a été un peu plus soutenue qu'en
France. Mais si vous voulez, tout ça
pour dire que euh on a
euh on n pas que des on n' pas qu'une
qu'une explication conjoncturelle,
d'accord, de on n pas qu'une explication
conjoncturelle de l'inflation. Je pense
que la part conjoncturelle de
l'inflation euh
est limité et on a dans on a dans cette
inflation, on a des facteurs plus
structurels qui sont qui sont liés au
fait que on a justement pas réalisé les
transitions
dont on a besoin. On n pas réduit notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles. On n'a
pas réalisé la transition énergétique et
ce faisant et bien on est
Est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
euh
Oui, on oui, on le peut bien sûr qu'on
le peut si on le veut mais en se dotant
des instruments en se dotant de en se
dotant des bons instruments pour le
faire. un vélo et de l'huile de coude.
Non, il faut plus que ça. Je pense que
est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut on parlait
des instruments de régulation des
marchés
est-ce qu'il faut peut-être un moment ou
un autre arrêter les conneries un peu
taper du point sur la table avec un gros
bâton derrière puis on va leur expliquer
gentiment que la séparation des banques
d'affaires, la séparation des banques de
détail maintenant c'est fait. Ouais.
Sinon, c'est quatre coups de bâton
prison. Et puis est-ce que ce serait
bien aussi de prendre notre armée puis
d'aller envahir directement les paradis
fiscaux ? On en a pas trop si on en a
quelques-uns près de nos frontières. En
plus, on se déplace pas loin. C'est
facile. Est-ce qu'il faudrait peut-être
un petit peu qu'on se fâche maintenant ?
Parce que je vois beaucoup de wish de
wishful sinking de de des petites sales
mait incantatoire à gauche à droite de
couloir de on va se doter d'eux on va
réguler on va avoir des fonds propres ça
va être vachement bien on va être saf
sécure continuez puis en fait derrière
ça marche pas puis dès dès qu'il y a un
écrétage qu'ils avaient pas prévu gen la
majeure partie du temps ils sont ils se
retrouvent tout perturbés puis derrière
c'est les états qui qui refinancent leur
petit jeu Puis derrière ça continue, ça
continue, ça continue. Est-ce que les
économistes il ferait peut-être un petit
peu les les énerver un peu, leur faire
une petite dotation comme à la
gendarmerie nationale ou la police leur
acheter 38 millions de grenades puis les
envoyer les faire de la régulation ?
Parce que quand je vous écoute,
je me dis c'est bien beau mais des
discours comme ça, on en a entendu plein
puis depuis des années puis des sing
tank qui réfléchissent à comment réguler
des plein puis des ministères qui font
des réunions aigu sur comment on va
stabiliser plein. Puis là ce qu'on voit
c'est une inflation qui commence à
piquer très fort.
H
des perspectives de résolution de cette
inflation mitigée.
proche du néant. Euh la capacité de
réindustrialiser notre pays proche du
néant et puis on continue d'entendre
beaucoup la communication. Donc après la
communication, il faut passer à
l'action. Hm
hm.
Donc est-ce que les économistes un petit
peu ont décidé de saisir le gouvernement
pour dire non ça suffit les conneries ?
Alors nous on travaille pas, on est on
prend du recul, on travaille sur notre
secteur d'activité, on voit ça d'un
regard neuf et là on va droit dans le
mur. Puis un mur tellement fort que ça
risque de créer des séquels en terme de
démocratie.
H
est-ce qu'il faut peut-être un petit peu
s'énerver ?
Alors
réveiller nos vieux démons ?
Ouais. Je pense qu'en tout cas, il faut
euh euh
il faut une résolution beaucoup plus
forte en effet à non, il faut une
résolution plus forte à agir et il faut
mobiliser les institutions dont on
dispose
pour agir.
Alors non, je crois que tout le monde
est pas d'accord avec ça. C'estd que par
exemple si vous voulez pour le
pour la régulation financière
dont vous avez commencé à à parler, on a
cette régulation financière, on l'a pas
suffisamment on l'a pas suffisamment
renforcé
à l'issue
à l'issue de la crise financière de
2007-2008 et je crois que on n'est pas
euh suffisamment résolu à la la faire
évoluer pour réorienter euh pour
réorienter la finance euh vers justement
nos objectifs vers nos objectifs
écologiques. Aujourd'hui, on a on a un
secteur bancaire et financier qui
continue de financer ce qu'il ne
faudrait plus financer, d'accord ? Qui
continue de financer les énergies les
énergies fossiles euh qui continue de de
financer des activités des activités
polluantes. Donc on a besoin de
réorienter assez drastiquement ces flux
financiers. Il est clair que on va pas
réorienter ces ces flux financiers
simplement en disant en disant aux
banques et aux autres aux autres acteurs
financiers, "Bon, maintenant, il faut
que vous preniez des engagements à euh à
mieux faire, surtout si ces engagements
sont pas contraignants." Donc ça veut
dire que il faut en passer en effet par
la mise en place de de réglementation
beaucoup plus forte qui euh commande aux
banques de euh de de décarboner leur
bilan, d'arrêter de financer le
d'arrêter de financer le fossile. Et je
pense que on a besoin pour faire ça de
réglementation qu'on a pas mise en place
d'ailleurs à l'issue de la crise
financière de 2007 2008. on a besoin de
réglementations
structurelles, c'est-à-dire des
réglementations qui agissent sur la
composition des bilans bancaires et pas
seulement sur des réglementations qui
consistent à demander aux banques
qu'elles aient un peu plus de qu'elles
aient un peu plus de fonds propres pour
absorber pour absorber leurs pertes.
C'est bien que les banques aient plus de
fonds propres, elles en ont pas assez et
certes ça a augmenté mais ça augmenté un
peu en en trompleœuil parce que ce sont
des ce sont des exigences qui sont
pondérées par les risques des actifs des
banques, risque que les banques évaluent
elles-mêmes. Donc en fait quand on voit
que les banques aujourd'hui ont 15 16 %
de de fonds propres, c'est en
pourcentage de leurs actifs pondérés par
les risques et quand on regarde ça
simplement en pourcentage du total du
bilan, bah ça fait ça fait 5 6 % de
fonds propre et 5 6 % de fonds propres,
c'est pas une grosse capacité
d'absorption des pertes. Donc ce serait
ce serait bien que les banques soient
plus solides financièrement, qu'elles
aient plus de fonds propres. cela étant
si on veut véritablement les amener à
mieux financer la la transition
écologique euh je pense qu'il suffira
pas en fait de leur dire attention le le
dérèglement climatique pour vous c'est
un ensemble de risque c'est un ensemble
de risque financiers sont alors ça pas
que les banques he d'ailleurs mais pour
les banques, les assurances les autres
acteurs financiers
il suffira pas de leur dire c'est du
risque de dommage c'est du risque de
transition
C'est du risque de responsabilité. Il
faut que vous preniez en compte les
risques financiers
induits par le dérèglement climatique et
il faut que vous soyez capable de de
faire face de faire face à ça. Je trouve
que ça au fond alors certes, si vous
voulez ça peut commencer à à à éveiller
un peu les conscience des des
financiers, mais c'est évidemment pas ce
qui va
leur permettre véritablement de financer
la transition. si on veut que les
banques et les autres acteurs du système
financier
vraiment se détourne de du financement
des activités qui
nous mènent dans qui nous qui nous
enfoncent dans la crise écologique et si
on veut les amener à financer ce qui va
nous permettre de construire un autre un
autre modèle de bifurquer vers un un
modèle qui soit qui soit respectueux que
des limites des limites planétaires et
bien il faut vraiment agir sur la
composition de leur bilan. Donc pour ça,
il nous faut des réglementations fortes,
des réglementations structurelles qui
interdisent les le financement des
activités fossiles et puis qui programme
la décarbonation des la décarbonation
des bilans bancaires. ce genre de
réglementation, ces réglementations
structurelles,
il est il est clair que pour le moment
les autorités
les autorités de régulation, le alors le
législateur comme les autorités de
supervision qui font appliquer les
règles sont pas du tout euh sont sont
pas du tout prêtes à ce genre de règle.
Et ça si elle ça renvoie si vous voulez
aussi à
à la conception qu'elles ont du système
financier. On disait tout à l'heure
qu'on est encore dans une vision où euh
euh
certes on reconnaît un peu
d'inefficience sur les d'inefficience au
sein du système financier,
d'inefficience
de toxicité, on dira.
Ouais. Voilà. De toxicité. Mais cette
inefficience et bien c'est pas les
autorités vont pas jusqu'à reconnaître
que c'est une inefficience dans
l'allocation des ressources. Donc elle
reste finalement persuadée que le marché
c'est la bonne façon d'allouer les
ressources. Et euh ce faisant et bien
euh elles sont pas, si vous voulez,
elles sont pas pour le moment euh
disposées à euh mettre en place des
règles euh qui
en quelque sorte euh commanderaient euh
cette allocation euh cette allocation
des ressources.
Alors, avant de passer une question
internet, h
si on leur mettait 6 mois de de prison
en Turquie, en Tcheniie, ça devrait les
motiver un peu plus, non ?
Vous voulez quoi ?
avoir installé une une responsabilité
pénale euh pour les euh pour les
banquiers, mettre euh réfléchir à ce
qu'on pourrait appeler l'écoide.
Euh
les formuler mais vous avez saisi les
je pense que la la finance si vous
voulez de manière manière assez assez
globale a une grande part de
responsabilité dans le dérèglement
climatique et
on serait sans doute plus résolu à la
transformer si on appréhendait en fait
le
comment dire le lien entre euh euh
finance et climat dans les deux sens.
C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui ce que euh
ce que les banques centrales, ce que les
autorités de supervision commencent à
avoir en tête, c'est que le dérèglement
climatique, c'est un problème pour la
finance. D'accord ? Mais ils sont pas du
tout encore prêts à reconnaître que la
finance est un problème pour le
dérèglement climatique. Quand on
arrivera à appréhender cette double
matérialité et là et bien en tant
qu'économiste,
on a on a un rôle à jouer. Il faut
vraiment qu'on
les prisons turques aussi hein. Si vous
voulez
6 mois dans une prison Turquie, vous
comprenez tout de suite le problème
écologique
non ? Euh
est-ce que c'est c'est un peu sarcasque
? Vous êtes vous êtes quand même du
genre très très autoritaire, hein.
Non. Sarcastique. Je pousse le trait je
je vois j'entends
h
la finance détruit le climat.
Finance des activités qui détruisent le
climat. H
bon bah derrière nous on va récupérer et
puis on va être obligé d'éponger.
Quand quand il y a trop de bordel après
une grosse fiesta
faut bien trouver quelqu'un qui va qui
va payer. Hm
hm. Il faudrait peut-être leur faire des
stages un petit peu avant l'histoire de
de les prévenir queon va se fâcher, que
la jeunesse la jeunesse va se fâcher
parce que là ils sont gentils, ils font
des grèves, il ils se cloent, il ils se
collent les mains avec de la résine,
c'est gentil encore.
Ouais.
Et un jour, ils vont se fâcher. Non,
non, mais vous avez raison. Je pense que
les tensions euh euh les tensions
sociales euh
euh les tensions sociales vont vont être
de plus en plus de plus en plus grandes.
Elle va créer quelque chose
d'autoritaire.
Le
euh
Allez, dites-le, dites- Non, mais on
voit bien si vous voulez que
Est-ce que vous voyez le truc sans sans
sans ce langage jargonneux de de
d'économiste,
c'est comme si on parlait au village.
Vous sentez le truc comment venir là ?
Non, ce que je sens c'est qu'on est euh
on est dans des démocraties qui euh qui
s'abîment, ça c'est clair, dans des
démocraties qui sont de plus en plus de
plus en plus fragiles et où pour
contenir euh ces tensions euh pour
contenir ces tensions sociales euh en
effet, on a on a un risque de euh on a
un risque de régime de régime de plus en
plus autoritaire. Euh euh oui. Donc ça
c'est euh euh c'est ce qu'il nous faut
euh euh c'est ce qu'il nous faut
absolument euh absolument éviter.
Question internet.
Hm.
Pourquoi les banques n'auraient-elles
plus le droit de financer l'activité
économique sans apporter la preuve de la
corrélation entre l'activité humaine et
le changement climatique immuable
d'après la personne qui pose la question
?
Hm hm.
Bah euh
en tout cas, si vous voulez euh
il faut, je crois euh
aujourd'hui euh faire en sorte que euh
euh
l'activité euh l'activité des banques
soit véritablement euh au service du
financement de la transition. Et pour ça
et bien euh
on peut euh
on pourrait mettre beaucoup plus de
conditions euh sur euh le leur
refinancement auprès de la banque
centrale. Euh il y a moyen
to fail.
Non non non pas du tout. Euh c'estd que
dans le cadre de euh dans le cadre de la
politique monétaire, dans le cadre des
refinancements que les banques
obtiennent auprès de la banque centrale,
et bien on pourrait tout à fait
conditionner euh le le prix de ce
refinancement, le taux euh de euh de ce
refinancement à la destination des
financements des financements des
banques. D'accord ? Donc euh alors vous
vous direz peut-être que ça bah c'est
pas suffisant mais ça ça s'appelle
Turquie,
ça s'appelle
ça s'appelle verdre, mais verdir la
politique monétaire dans le bon sens du
terme, c'est-à-dire pas dans le sens pas
dans le sens du green washing.
C'està-dire que je pense qu'on peut euh
on peut véritablement
euh
transformer euh transformer la politique
monétaire. Euh on peut euh on peut la
mettre au service de la transition. On
peut la mettre au service de la
transition écologique. Euh ça euh
en combien de temps ?
Bah en combien de temps il faudrait que
il faudrait que nos euh
il y a qu'un faucon quoi.
Non c'est pas ça. C'est que euh il faut
bien sûr il faut une volonté il faut ils
faut une volonté de le faire.
Volonté politique. Volonté politique.
Ouais. Il faut une volonté politique de
le faire. Il faut la volonté politique
de mettre les banques centrales qui sont
des institutions puissantes euh au
service
très démocratique d'ailleurs. Non.
Alors, ben justement, c'est le problème,
c'estàd que euh on a été, si vous
voulez, longtemps euh longtemps
persuadé, hein, que euh des euh euh
les banques centrales pouvaient être des
institutions des institutions
indépendantes et que euh plus euh plus
elles étaient indépendantes et mieux
c'était pour euh pour les les missions
qu'on leur confiait. Sachant que la
mission qu'on leur a euh qu'on leur
confie depuis des décennies, c'est euh
c'est la stabilité c'est la stabilité
des prix, c'est la stabilité c'est la
stabilité monétaire. Euh je crois
qu'aujourd'hui en fait, il faudrait euh
qu'on prenne conscience du euh du
pouvoir monétaire des banques centrales,
pouvoir monétaire qu'elles ont mis au
service du rétablissement des marchés et
des banques à l'issue de
pendant pendant la crise financière pour
gérer la crise financière et et pendant
la crise sanitaire, ce pouvoir
monétaire, plutôt que de le de le mettre
systématiquement
au service des banques et des marché et
bien il faut le mettre au service il
faut le mettre au service de la société,
il faut le mettre au service de
l'économie. Alors
je peux faire l'avocat du diable ?
Ouais
la crise de 2008. Bon il y a quelques
petits peu de petits peu scrupuleux qui
se sont amusés à distribuer des crédits
un peu n'importe comment. Ça a créé une
bulle. C'est ça si je suis bien. Cette
bulle a été trisée dans différents
produits qui a créé d'autres bulles et
on passé les meilleurs.
Là les choses ont pas changé de
grand-chose. L'échelle l'échelle a
continué d'augmenter. On est d'accord.
Il y a plus de bulles, plus de
liquidité, plus de machin, plus de plus
de tout quoi.
Oui, c'est ça.
Et la réglementation, c'est un petit peu
du je te conseille deux, tu comprends
parce que on va avoir un climat qui sera
pas beau, donc fais quand même des
investissements.
On parlait pas, on parlait pas climat,
hein. Euh en si vous voulez en en euh en
2008 2009, euh je crois que le euh le
climat, on avait pas on on en avait pas
du tout conscience. C'estàd que les
banques centrales étaient euh
complètement ignorantes euh de euh la
question climatique euh
en 2008-2009. La prise de conscience,
elle est beaucoup plus récente. La prise
de conscience, elle date euh elle date
de la COP 21, elle date de 2015. Alors,
elle date, on va quand même mettre ça à
son actif de du fameux discours de de
Marc Carnet quelques mois avant la COP
21 quand il s'adresse à un parterre de
financiers et quand il leur dit
"Attention euh faites attention quand
même, il y a cette fameuse tragédie des
horizons.
votre horizon court termiste est pas
compatible avec l'horizon long de auquel
il nous faut agir pour
agir pour le pour le climat et puis
surtout et bien c'est le moment où il
leur dit que le le dérèglement
climatique ça représente des risques
financiers pour eux. Donc c'est la prise
de conscience, elle date elle date de
2015. C'est hyper récent. Il y a avant
Chirac notre maison brûle et nous
regardons ailleurs là. C'est ça.
Oui, ça bien sûr. Mais c'était pas
c'était pas à l'adresse des banques
centrales.
Écoutez pas. C'est vrai que les gens
dans les banques centrales, c'est pas
des gens,
c'est c'est une autre race de gens.
C'est c'est extratérons
il y a des gens dans les banques
centrales mais il y a effectivement une
il y a un grand conservatisme dans les
banques centrales.
Et si on leur dit dans les banques
centrales, dans les banques tout courts,
dans tout ça, votre perspective des
horizons là. Turquie 6 mois.
Vous insistez euh vous voulez
on vous envoie les Césars les chars
d'assaut
donc vous voulez enfermer vous voulez
enfermer les Ouais. Vous voulez enfermer
les banquiers les banquers banqu les
enfermés on les en Turquie
histoire de les préparer de les
attendrire les les
Non je crois qu'il faut il faut être
plus ferme. Ça c'est c'est bien clair.
Il faut être plus ferme dans la il faut
être plus ferme dans la régulation
financière. Je
fais le truc je fais exprès. On s'est
bien compris.
Ouais. Oui. Il faut être plus ferme dans
la régulation financière. Mais c'est si
vous voulez
alors je lis la question qui qui est un
commentaire
euh d'un internaute.
Mais ce n'est pas les banques qui font
les réglementations qui ensuite validé
par les institutions pourinterrogation
conscience et financier
pourinterrogation et si on demandait au
Père Noël de régler le problème ? Bon
alors je suis pas sûr de bien comprendre
la question mais
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai malheureusement que pas des
héroïnomanes qui ont les clés de la
pharmacie centrale de l'hôpital
oui c'est un petit peu ça c'estd que
euh on a en effet
un lobby bancaire qui est un lobby
bancaire et financier qui est largement
capable d'influencer
euh
d'influencer les règles bancaires
Euh donc euh ça en effet c'est quelque
chose de d'absolument
euh d'absolument désastreux. Euh et on a
euh si vous voulez une euh on on a une
une culture euh bancaire et financière
qui s'est euh qui s'est diffusé partout
en fait hein parmi les euh euh parmi les
gouvernants qui s'est euh qui s'est
diffusé au sein des banques centrales,
au sein des instances de supervision
parce que ces institutions recrutent
beaucoup en fait parmi les parmi les les
banquiers et
les financiers. en partant du principe
que le système financier s'est tellement
développé, il est devenu tellement
complexe que on a besoin de leur
expertise et donc il faut installer à la
tête des à la tête des banques
centrales, à la tête des autorités de
supervision et bien des experts du du
seur du secteur. Et donc en mettant en
mettant à la tête de ces institutions
des experts du secteur, et bien on a
forcément des gens qui sont très
imprégnés par les intérêts du secteur,
qui sont pas très enclins ensuite à le à
le à le réguler et progressivement et
bien on confond si vous voulez le
l'intérêt l'intérêt général et puis
l'intérêt l'intérêt du secteur l'intérêt
du secteur bancaire et financier qui est
très très présent. Oui, c'est mon c'est
mon interprétation, mais c'est une
interprétation qui est assez largement
partagée par ceux qui s'intéressent à ce
qu'on appelle la capture du la la la
capture des des gouvernants par le
secteur par le secteur bancaire et
financier. C'est quelque chose d'assez
insidieux. de gauche, ça. Je suis sûr
que ces gens-là, ils sont tous de gauche
et économistes. Non,
non, non, c'est euh Non, il y a des
travaux euh
les sources,
il y a des travaux hyper il y a des
travaux hyper sérieux, hein, sur ces sur
ces questionsl Non non non, pas du tout.
Euh je pense tiens à notamment au au
travail de mon de mon collègue Ariel
Ariel Réchef à l'université de de
Parisien qui avait euh euh fait une
grosse étude empirique pour regarder le
le parcours des le parcours des
banquiers des banquiers centraux euh
avec une économiste de la Banque
mondiale. Donc ils avaient fait ils
avaient fait une grosse base de données
sur le parcours des banquiers centraux
et
ils étaient parvenus à montrer que quand
les banquiers centraux sont issus du
secteur bancaire et financier et en
renseignant cette tendance en montrant
que c'était de plus en plus le cas qu'il
y avait à peu près un/ers des banquiers
centraux aujourd'hui qui étaient issus
du du secteur bancaire et financier et
que quand c'est le cas et bien ils sont
évidemment beaucoup plus enclins à
déréguler le secteur bancaire et
financier qu'à le qu'à le réguler. Donc
ça marche aussi pour les présidents de
la République ça.
Bah oui, il y a ce phénomène si vous
voulez qu'on appelle les les les
phénomènes des des revolving doors avec
des des allers-retours entre la haute
fonction publique, voir la très haute
fonction publique et puis le le secteur
bancaire et financier. euh pas mal de
pas mal d'aller-retour dans ce dans ce
genre-là et qui sert à justement à à
diffuser à la la culture la culture
bancaire et financière partout. Ouais.
Ouais. Et qui fait valoir ensuite les
intérêts les intérêts du secteur
bancaire et financier partout. Donc bon,
tout ça pour dire que la régulation
la régulation du secteur bancaire et
financier a été largement
entravé par entravé par ça. Mais je
crois que
aujourd'hui les transformations dont on
a besoin sont pas simplement des
transformations au niveau de la
régulation financière. Moi, j'ai très
longtemps bossé sur la la régulation
bancaire et financière et et
très longtemps penser que on finalement
les choses iraient mieux en
régulant plus fortement. Mais je crois
aujourd'hui que on a besoin également de
transformation plus profonde et
de transformation
de transformation au niveau monétaire.
Euh je pense qu'on a besoin de repenser
la monnaie aujourd'hui en fait si on
veut euh si on veut réaliser la euh la
transformation euh euh la transformation
euh écologique et euh et social euh dont
on a besoin. Je suis pas sûr qu'on
arrivera à faire ces transformations euh
simplement avec la monnaie telle qu'on
la connaît aujourd'hui, avec la monnaie
créée par les banques, avec cette
monnaie qu'on empreinte, avec cette
monnaie qu'on achète. Euh je crois qu'en
fait on a euh
on a besoin euh de euh de mobiliser
beaucoup plus fortement euh ces
institutions que sont les banques
centrales et euh on a besoin euh
qu'elle-même euh euh créer de la monnaie
selon un mode différent. Alors
aujourd'hui, les banques centrales
créent de la monnaie centrale qui est
utilisable
qui est utilisable uniquement par
uniquement par les banques. D'accord ?
C'est la c'est la monnaie que les
banques utilisent pour se régler entre
elles, pour se payer.
C'est quoi le nom de la banque des
banques ? Comment ça s'appelle cette
banque-là ?
La banque des règlements internationaux.
Non, c'est ça. Vous Mais là, je vous
parle pas de la banque des règlements
internationaux en fait. Je je euh je
vous parle des banques centrales qui
sont effectivement alors c'était
peut-être ça que vous vouliez dire qui
sont les banques centrales. On appelle
ça les banques des banques. D'accord ?
c'est les banques se financent auprès de
la banque centrale et elle se règle
entre elles avec la monnaie qu'elles
empruntent euh à
la banque centrale. Et donc la banque
centrale aujourd'hui euh crée de la
monnaie selon à peu près le même
processus que selon le même processus
que les que les banques. C'estàd que
quand
les banques centrales empruntent pardon,
quand les banques commerciales
empruntent à la banque centrale, et bien
la banque centrale crée de la monnaie.
Quand la banque centrale achète des
titres sur les marchés financiers, et
bien la banque centrale crée de la
monnaie. Donc il y a cette création de
cette création de monnaie centrale
aujourd'hui qui est au service des
banques, au service des marchés
financiers. Et bien, je crois qu'en fait
on pourrait, si vous voulez euh euh on
peut tout à fait imaginer hein que euh
les banques central euh euh créent euh
de la monnaie euh pour la mettre
directement au service des
investissements publics dont on a besoin
dans
dans la transition dans la transition
écologique. Je pense que on a besoin
aujourd'hui que les banques centrales
euh mettent leur leur pouvoir monétaire
euh
au service au service des États. Alors,
en le faisant
en le faisant dans un cadre de
gouvernance profondément rénové, c'estd
que je pense pas non plus qu'une fusion
qu'une fusion complète entre banque
centrale et État, ce serait une très
très bonne chose parce que voyez
justement si ça se passait dans votre
état turc pourrait être assez euh assez
assez problématique. Donc on a besoin en
fait la Banque d'Angleterre si vous
voulez hein.
Oui. Oui. par exemple. Donc on a besoin
en fait de repenser la gouvernance des
de repenser la gouvernance des banques
centrales.
Je peux vous couper ? Ouais.
Donc on a besoin, il y a qu'à faucon, on
a besoin de repenser, on a besoin pour
moi, je trouve ça magnifique. C'est
beau, c'est c'est plein d'espérance,
c'est c'est plein de lunettes roses.
Bon, nous on est un peu plus terre à
terre ici. On est opératif,
opérationnel.
Nous nous on fait
Mais donc vous faites comment vous ?
Et ben nous on débarque, on les prend
tous un parin et puis on leur dit
maintenant
c'est comme ça
ou sinon c'est Turquie.
Ouais mais
on va y arriver. On va y arriver. Si on
se tape un gros choc financier que les
institutions calanchent, que les
services publics calanchent,
les gens ils vont s'énerver un peu.
Au milieu de ses énervés, on prend les
sans plus énervés. Ah.
Alors divenez les gars,
on va monter à Bruxelles et on va leur
poser des questions parce que notre
avenir climatique bon ça c'est un truc
de pour les jeunes dans 20 30 ans.
Non non c'est maintenant.
Ah bon ? Ouais on avait pas remarqué. Et
donc qui aurait pu prédire ça ?
C'est vrai qu' aurait pu qui aurait pu
prédire
qui aurait pu
qui est payé pour prédire d'ailleurs moi
c'est c'est en fait la question qu'il
faudrait poser c'est qui est payé pour
prédire depuis 10 ans ? Hm.
C'est tu rends ton salaire des 10
dernières années puis tu vas faire un
petit séjour en Turquie.
Puis on va en reparler puis comme ça on
va avoir des meilleurs des gens qui
anticipent.
Non non, je suis d'accord. Je suis je
suis d'accord pour dire que c'est
effectivement tout à fait coupable de
dire qui aurait pu qui aurait pu prédire
la crise écologique. Mais je suis pas
non plus pour l'enferement dans dans les
prises en turque. Non non mais non mais
il faut savoir faire passer un message.
On peut on peut délirer. Il y a un
nord-coréen qui va bien c'est les trucs
qui va
c'est du wishful sinking. C'est des
incantations. C'est il faudrait il y a
qu'à et puis résultat des courses leur
tournent les bulles au grossissent on
les laisse faire ce qu'ils veulent. Puis
quand nous on va se taper une vraie
crise financière avec le prix de les
marchés de l'immobilier qui se casse la
gueule, l'euro le prix de l'euro qui se
casse la gueule, une une déflation
dingue sur certains actifs, une
inflation dingue sur certains actifs,
donc une stackflation. Quand on va avoir
une misère, plus d'hôpital,
19h d'hôpital pour aller crever sur un
brancard,
il y a un moment il faut arrêter. Quand
on est chef d'entreprise, quand on
regarde une autre entreprise faire de la
cavalerie à gogo avec les mêmes
toxicomanes qui ont les clés du trésor,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Soit on envoie la
police
puis c'est prison.
H non mais
soit on fait quoi ?
Il faut une volonté citoyenne forte. Ben
oui, bien sûr, il faut une volonté
citoyenne forte. Pour ça, ben il faut
justement que pas mal de pas mal de gens
se mobilisent pour
on fait des kermess
mais non, on fait on fait pas on fait
pas des kermess
on fait quoi
un téléton pour le climat ?
Non, je crois qu'on a on a besoin en
tout cas on a besoin de euh on a besoin
de beaucoup de pédagogie, on a besoin
d'expliquer on a besoin d'expliquer les
choses euh pour mobilis
pour mobiliser les citoyens. Bah, il
faut aussi, si vous voulez euh qu'on
réalise que tout ça sera euh très
coûteux.
Est-ce que la pédagogie de la taloche
fonctionne avec le banquier central ?
Est-ce que la pédagogie fonctionne avec
Est-ce que la pédagogie de la taloche h
fonctionne avec le banquier ou le
banquier central
à votre avis ? Mais une une de bûcheron,
genre un truc bien pédagogique.
Hm. Euh
je suis pas pour la pédagogie de la
taloche, je suis pour euh
ça me ça me ça me parle pas trop ça,
mais vous avez raison hein. Je suis
peut-être un peu trop euh oui. Euh
ouais, je Non, je suis pas je suis pas
je suis peut-être un peu trop
un peu trop bisouours de ce de ce point
de vue-là. Mais euh moi j'aimerais bien
que ça vienne en fait des que ça vienne
des citoyens, que les citoyennes que les
citoyens réalisent euh la nécessité de
ce changement et qu'il vote en fait pour
on va leur expliquer la nécessité de ce
changement. Qu'est-ce qui va se passer
s'il y a pas ce changement-là
? Et ben effectivement,
s'il y a pas ce changement là, on ira
droit dans le mur et nos enfants et
petits-enfants n'habiteront plus sur
droit dans le mur, ça veut dire ça veut
rien dire à personne. Il faut il faut
délayer ça, faut mettre en appétit. Faut
décrire la recette de comment on arrive
dans le mur et les conséquences. C'est
essayer de me décrire ça comme un
médecin qui va expliquer un cancer
osseux métastasé
à son patient.
Vous avez déjà discuté avec un
cancérologue ?
Non, pas encore mais bon, ça pourrait
venir.
Ouis. Donc essayez en tant qu'économiste
de prendre la place du médecin
et d'expliquer un patient qui est
cancéreux que l'ablation chirurgicale
dans les métastases osseuses, faut qu'il
oublie et que ça va bien être
douloureux. Donc arriver droit dans le
mur, ça ressemble à quoi
en détail ? Arriver droit dans le mur,
c'est une conjonction si vous voulez de
crise
écologique, sociale, politique. C'est un
c'est tout ça.
Commençons par la financière. Une bonne
une bonne crise financière, on arrive
dans le mur. C'est quoi ? C'est un
effondrement à l'Argentine ? C'est un
effondrement façon africain, façon
libanais.
C'est comment ? Quel goût ça a ? Ben,
une crise financière, c'est euh
c'est euh euh ce sont des retombées
économiques euh absolument euh
absolument terribles. C'est euh euh
c'est une rupture, c'est une c'est une
si vous voulez c'est un appauvrissement
généralisé. Euh ce sont euh des euh
c'est un système c'est un secteur
bancaire qui ne euh c'est un secteur
bancaire qui fonctionne plus. ce sont
des des marchés financiers qui sont euh
qui sont à l'arrêt et des retombées et
des retombées économiques qui sont euh
qui sont dramatiques, beaucoup de euh
beaucoup de de chômage, des capacités de
production complètement complètement
détruites. Bon, on a
aujourd'hui ces ces crises financières
sont
géré en en mobilisant le pouvoir
monétaire des banques centrales.
Le problème au fond, c'est que ce
pouvoir monétaire est toujours mis au
service du rétablissement des banques et
des marchés et pas au service du
rétablissement de l'économie réelle et
en l'occurrence de la transformation de
de l'économie réelle. Donc c'est euh
voilà, je crois que c'est ça le
c'est ça la
question question internet dans votre
pire scénario de crise financière.
Alors, je rappelle encore une fois que
nous ne sommes pas là pour disséminer et
donner des conseils financiers aux gens
qui nous écoutent.
On passe le bonjour à l'Autorité des
marchés financiers et et sa bonne année.
Question d'internet. Dans votre pire
scénario de crise financière, les
Français pourraient-ils perdre leur
épargne si les banques s'effondraient ?
Quel conseil ? On donne pas conseil. Hm.
Bon euh
est-ce que est-ce que le français peut
perdre ses actifs en banque à moins de
70000 € par banqu
? C'est 72000
par banqu 100000
avant ou après que sapin a dit qu'il
allait faire un effet de levier parce
que son fond my
ne pouvait sponsoriser que
non les dépôts les dépôts
le fond garantie des dépôts bancaires.
C'est ça
combien les dépôts sont garantis jusqu'à
100000 € par déposant et par banque.
Donc euh voilà ça veut dire que pour ce
pour tous ceux qui vous écoutent qui
et par établissement
exactement. Ouais, par
c'est pas par banque, c'est un compte
dans une banque. C'est terminé.
Oui, mais ça veut dire que vous pouvez
avoir plusieurs comptes effectivement et
puis euh
avoir disposé de cette garantie des
dépôts sur un sur un montant sur un
montant plus important. Donc ça veut
dire que euh aujourd'hui, si vous
voulez, vous avez vous avez cette
garantie des dépôts qui fonctionne à une
échelle nationale qui est plus là quand
même pour sans doute
papipo pour rassurer. C'est de la
bobologie.
C'est plus un instrument en effet qui
est là pour pour rassurer pour dissuader
pour dissuader les paniques bancaires
parce que vous m'interrogiez tout à
l'heure sur ça ressemble à quoi ça
ressemble à quoi une crise financière ?
euh une crise financière, ça peut
ressembler effectivement à des à un
mouvement un mouvement généralisé de de
panique. Alors, le mouvement généralisé
de panique, c'est plus justement euh un
mouvement de de rué au guichet comme on
on a pu voir ça dans les dans les années
dans les années 30, notamment au guichet
des banques des banques américaines. Euh
c'est plus ça parce que il y a euh a été
mis en place ensuite la garantie des
dépôts. Mais aujourd'hui ça peut être
des phénomènes de rué sur les marchés
interbancaires. Il y a plein de il y a
des liens très très forts aujourd'hui
sur au sein du système financier entre
les banques et d'autres institutions et
d'autres institutions financières qui
peuvent ensuite et bien venir récupérer
les les liquidités qu'elles ont auprès
des des auprès des banques. Et donc vous
avez ensuite un un phénomène
un phénomène de rué qui peut qui peut
s'amplifier et donc des des
pertes de des pertes de valeur des
pertes de valeur colossales et
un dysfonctionnement une
dysfonctionnement total du du système du
système bancaire et financier et donc
une économie qui est complètement voilà
complètement à l'arrêt. un peu perdu le
fil là de
C'est plausible ou c'est envisageable ça
? Euh on
en Europe en Europe.
Bah ce qui est plausible en en fait ce
qui est plausible aujourd'hui c'est euh
c'est une crise financière encore plus
forte que euh celle qu'on a connu euh
celle qu'on a connu en 2008. euh parce
que euh justement le on n'a pas euh on
n' pas soigné euh fondamentalement le
euh euh le le secteur bancaire et
financier de ces euh de ces
dysfonctionnements, de ces de ces
dérives. On n'a pas corrigé
l'hypertrophie financière. Donc euh
aujourd'hui, si les bulles explosent, on
va avoir une crise financière on va
avoir une crise financière encore plus
forte avec des retombées économiques qui
seront euh qui seront extrêmement
fortes. On a plus de
cap. En fait, on n pas mis de frein. On
a on n pas mis beaucoup de frein. On a
mis quelques coussins de d'absorption de
quelques coussins d'amortissement,
quelques coussin d'absorption des des
pertes, mais on a surtout finalement
continué d'appuyer sur l'accélérateur.
C'estd que les
banques centrales nous ont
essayé de de nous soigner des des crises
passées en en préparant les crises les
crises futures. qu'on a on a finalement
toujours le pied sur l'accélérateur sur
l'accélérateur financier et euh là on
est on est dans une phase oui où tout ça
pourrait
tout ça pourrait euh de nouveau de
nouveau exploser, ce qui nous mettrait
dans une incapacité totale à
à à
soigner les tensions les tensions
sociales du moment. ça ne pourra que les
que les exacerber et puis ce qui nous
mettra dans une incapacité totale aussi
à à à effectuer les transformation à
part si au fond ce ça constitue un
détonateur euh encore plus fort et si
c'est ça qui permet si c'est ça qui
permet la prise de conscience.
Vous y croyez à la destruction créatrice
?
Euh non, je crois pas forcément à la
destruction créatrice, mais en tout cas
euh je pense qu'il faut des moments de
crise euh euh profonde pour accoucher de
de changements importants. ce qui est
euh euh
ce qui est assez euh ce qui est assez
déprimant, c'est de constater que toutes
les crises qu'on a traversé jusqu'à
présent n'ont pas été suffisantes pour
impulser ces pour impulser ces
changements, que les changements à
chaque fois ont été trop petits par
rapport à ce qu'il par rapport à ce dont
on aurait besoin. Donc et ce qui est
dommage aussi, c'est de
d'en arriver si vous voulez à penser que
il faudrait une crise encore plus
dramatique pour arriver à
pour arriver à à réaliser.
Donc faut toucher le fond pour pouvoir
rebondir. C'est ça.
Bah c'est euh
c'est rebond du chamb.
Ouais. Malheureusement, c'est un peu
Malheureusement, c'est un peu ça.
C'estàd que il faut ces moments de crise
pour il faut ces moments de crise pour
rebondir. Mais
ça tombe bien,
il y en a un gros qui arrive. Question
internet. Est-ce que vous pensez à un
craque immobilier pour bientôt ? Alors,
le l'immobilier, c'est un secteur qui a
été euh suralimenté par euh la politique
euh monétaire très accommodante alors
qui a été euh euh qui a été mené euh
qui a été mené à la fois, si vous voulez
au début euh au début des années 2000,
ce qui a conduit ce qui a conduit à la
crise financière, mais qui a été de
nouveau suralimenté après par la gestion
de crise financière et par la gestion de
crise sanitaire. C'est que quand les
taux ont été véritablement au tout le
temps que les taux ont été au plancher,
et bien ça a favorisé euh ça a favorisé
le
ça a favorisé le largement le crédit
immobilier. Et ça c'est un aspect
important en fait de la je dirais de euh
de l'activité de l'activité des banques
euh soutenu par les banques centrales.
En fait depuis plusieurs décennies euh
le l'activité des banques s'est
transformée et euh quand les banques
font du crédit, ce qui est plus le cœur
de leur activité, quand les banques font
du crédit, c'est pas du crédit qui va au
financement des entreprises, c'est
beaucoup de crédit qui va à
l'immobilier. Et euh donc euh ça veut
dire si vous voulez que euh les soutiens
en fait le soutien financier dont les
banques ont bénéficié a été assez
largement répercuté sur le secteur de
l'immobilier et euh donc toute la
gestion de crise financière et sanitaire
a pas mal contribué à nourrir
une bulle immobilière et cette bulle
immobilière maintenant que les taux
remontent et bien elle pourrait elle
pourrait exploser. Donc s'il y a
voilà si cette bulle si cette bulle
explose,
oui, il pourrait y avoir un un craque
immobilier. Et ça veut dire que
euh
[Musique]
il faut que les taux augmentent un peu
pour arriver si vous voulez à dégonfler
les bulles. Euh il faut pas que les taux
augmentent trop vite euh sinon euh ces
bulles ces ces bulles exploseront euh
brutalement. Alors, on peut euh on on
peut analyser les choses de différentes
manières. C'est qu'on peut se dire au
fond de toute façon ces bulles ont enfin
c'est ces bulles la bulle immobilière
est devenue tellement grosse, le coût du
logement est devenu tellement important
en répercussion hein de la formation de
ces bulles immobilières qu'au fond si la
bulle explose et bien tant mieux on
repartira sur de on repartira sur de
bonnes bases. Mais
c'est toujours l'explosion d'une
l'explosion d'une bulle,
d'une bulle immobilière, d'une bulle
financière, c'est toujours très
appauvrissant pour l'économie et ce sont
pas ce sont pas ceux qui se sont
enrichis pendant la bulle qui pâtissent
le plus du dégonflement de
de la bulle. Oui. ou souvent les plus
modestes parce que les plus modestes
trinquent ensuite du fait des des des
répercussions dans l'économie réelle, du
fait de euh de l'augmentation du
chômage, des destructions des capacités
de production de euh voilà. Donc
pour vous, les les trois quatre plus
grosses menaces sur le système financier
à l'heure actuel ou sur l'économie
française, c'est quoi ?
Le euh
Bruno Lemer, on n pas le droit de le
dire. D'accord.
hein, le je crois que si vous voulez la
euh
la menace la menace essentielle mais qui
me semble une menace assez euh assez
large, c'est que euh euh on a continué
d'alimenter et de suralimenter euh la
dette euh euh la dette en gérant euh en
gérant les crises. Donc euh c'est euh
ces dettes
euh euh le espèce de bullle de de de
dette peuvent aujourd'hui peuvent
peuvent aujourd'hui exploser avec avec
l'augmentation avec l'augmentation des
taux et
l'augmentation des taux n'est pas
à la fois enfin je dirais que
l'augmentation des taux est pas est pas
terminée. D'accord. Donc les les banques
centrales vont continuer d'augmenter
vont continuer d'augmenter les taux.
Elles vont peut-être le faire un peu
moins un peu moins fortement que dans
les mois précédents, mais elles vont
continuer de elles vont continuer de le
faire parce que elles sont euh elles
sont euh
elles sont un peu obligées de faire
comme si elles avaient les armes pour
lutter contre l'inflation. Donc elles
vont
elles agitent les bras, c'est ça ?
Oui, elles agitent les bras. Alors, je
suis un peu euh euh
je dirais
ça va mal se terminer cette histoire là,
hein. En fait, ça ça pourrait mieux se
terminer si euh les banques centrales
euh
pilotaient cette remontée des taux
d'intérêt euh justement en euh euh en
tenant compte davantage euh de euh en
tenant en compte de la stabilité
financière et en faisant dépendre aussi
le niveau des des taux d'intérêt auquels
elle refinance les banques, de
la destination des financements des
financements des banques. Si s'il y
avait ces je dirais ces leviers là, s'il
y avait ce euh ou en tout cas s'il y
avait ces objectifs là, si les banques
centrales avaient euh davantage un
objectif de stabilité financière et puis
un objectif de fort de contribution euh
un objectif climatique, un objectif de
de contribution au financement de la de
la transition écologique ou un objectif
de de réorientation des des flux
financiers
Je pense qu'elle piloterait en fait le
la remontée des taux autrement, mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout comme ça
qu'elle qu'elle pilote la remontée des
taux. c'est qu'elle pilote pas la
remontée des taux en se disant on va
faire attention à ce que
on va faire attention à essayer de de
recouvrir la stabilité financière et on
va se mobiliser pour la transition
écologique. Aujourd'hui, elle pilote la
remontée des taux en se disant en
essayant de se convaincre que elles vont
elles vont ramener l'inflation au niveau
de leur cible. Mais si l'inflation du
moment est pas finalement est pas une
inflation conjoncturelle et pas une
inflation monétaire, bah elles pourront
pas grand-chose avec leur remontée des
taux d'intérêt. Mais en revanche, ce
qu'elles pourront, si elles sont pas
attentives aux conséquences financières
de
la remontée des taux, elles pourront
faire exploser les bulles. Et si elles
font
fait on fait un paris entre vous et moi,
vous pensez que les banques centrales,
elles sont capables de gérer le truc à
quoi on met on met quoi ? Mes 5 € sur la
table, je vous parais qu'elles sont pas
capables de le faire.
Vous pensez que vous êtes qu'elles sont
capables de le faire ou est-ce que vous
vous seriez prêt à vous faire couper les
deux mains tout de suite ?
Il y a ce que euh
au bout d'un certain souhaite et puis il
y a le
au bout d'un certain temps des
économistes on entend beaucoup essayer
de rassurer, de meubler, d'expliquer
et puis là on est en 2023 quand même.
Il faut il faut quand même passer à
l'action. C'est c'est
soit on fait confiance, soit on fait pas
confiance.
Vous leur faites confiance pour plus de
tel truc ou pas ? Oui ou non ? Non, mais
je Non non euh non euh je pense que
si vous leur faites pas confiance, à
quoi ça sert d'essayer de prodier des
conseils ? Il faut peut-être changer de
stratégie. Mais c'est important en fait,
c'est important de comprendre euh euh
que ce sont des institutions dotées d'un
grand pouvoir et que ce
billet pour la Turquie, ça va les
réveiller tout de suite.
Non, mais c'est pas euh je pense que ça
marche.
Turquie est un pays magnifique
d'ailleurs.
Oui.
En prison, je sais pas trop.
Euh non, je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit
euh collectivement conscient du pouvoir
de ces institutions et qu'on récupère le
pouvoir de ces institutions.
Vous avez lu dernière biographie de
Nabila ? Non.
C'est pour ça. Vous y croyez encore
?
Peut-être. Mais
je fais des boutades. Je fais des
boutades. Mais est-ce que vous comprenez
un peu mon énervement ?
Oui. Oui, je comprends votre énervement.
Mais si vous voulez, moi aussi je euh
j'ai une forme de j'ai une forme de
désespoir, mais j'essaie de le euh
comment dire ? J'essaie de le de le
contrebalancer
par euh
des réflexions sur ce qu'il faudrait et
ensuite sur la transmission de ces de
ces de ces réflexions. Et je pense qu'on
a euh
on pourrait tout à fait se
on pourrait tout à fait se doter des des
instruments nécessaires à la réalisation
de cette transformation.
on a des institutions extrêmement
puissantes
euh euh dont on voilà dont on devrait se
qu'on devrait mettre à notre service et
il faut il faut réaliser ce pouvoir-là.
Et tout à l'heure euh j'ai pas j'ai pas
pu véritablement euh euh poursuivre sur
la la transformation monétaire dont on a
euh dont on a besoin. Mais je pense que
si euh euh
si on mettait le pouvoir monétaire des
banques centrales au service du
financement de la transition écologique,
on avancerait dans on avancerait dans la
transformation dont on a besoin. Si on
mettait le pouvoir de l'Église
catholique
pour arrêter de manger de la viande. Ça
marcherait à votre avis ? Ça m'intéresse
pas trop ça.
Et j'ai un copain qui a essayé, il était
voir le cardinal noir, il a dit "Écoute,
ça fait 2000 ans que vous êtes les chefs
de la propagande à vous assurer.
Là, il faudrait dire à vos o qu' il faut
arrêter de manger de la viande." Bon bah
ça va pas marcher.
Alors bon euh
est-ce que c'est à peu près du même
Akabi ? que
alors non, c'est pas c'est pas du même
Akabi. C'estd que on a
bien sûr si vous voulez
qu'individuellement on a plein de on a
également plein de
de transformation à opérer. On doit
individuellement modifier nos
comportements. Peut-être que manger
manger un manger moins de viande, ça
fait partie des choses qui seraient sans
doute utiles individuellement. Mais moi
ce dont je vous parlais c'est plus de
sa wifi, sa box wifi aussi ça marche.
Oui oui mais ça ça
un col roulé
si vous voulez mais tout c'est c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas inutile tout ça mais
il faut euh également
des actions des actions publiques très
fortes. D'accord. Donc c'est pas
simplement des actions
c'est non c'est pas
petit défilé dans la rue
c'est pas simplement des
un peu de peinture sur un ministère se
coller la main. On a surtout besoin que
tout aille dans le même sens, soit mis
en cohérence et aille vers le même euh
vers le même objectif euh de euh de
transformation. Donc oui, on a
individuellement bien sûr qu'on a besoin
de on a besoin de de on a besoin de de
transformer de transformer nos
comportements, mais on a surtout besoin
de réaliser le pouvoir de nos
institutions et de les mettre au service
de cette transformation. Les banques
centrales, ce sont des institutions
ultra puissantes euh qu'on devrait
mettre au service de la société si elle
prêtait de l'argent directement aux
États. qui même elle donner de l'argent
aux États pour réaliser la masse
d'investissement public dont on a besoin
pour réaliser
les transformations dans le domaine euh
dans le domaine dans le domaine
énergétique, dans le domaine dans le
domaine social pour établir les services
publics et cetera. Mais je crois que en
fait nos sociétés se porteraient nos
sociétés se porteraient beaucoup mieux.
Alors
après voilà,
comment on fait si vous voulez pour
pour avoir ce pour avoir ce déclic. D'où
viendra ce déclic ? Vous vous êtes dans
la méthode un peu un peu autoritaire.
Moi je
Non non, ça c'est pas une méthode.
Ça c'est pas une méthode. C'est une
boutade. Genre une bonne taloche de
bûcheron et un billet pour la Turquie.
C'est une boutade.
Bah oui, mais je sais pas. Je sais pas.
Et ma pauvre dame, si je devais mettre
en application mon raisonnement
en 2 minutes, ils prennent les réformes
les réformes.
S'ils avaient le quart du 10e de ce que
j'ai dans la tête, h
je peux vous dire qu'ils ferait leur
travail.
Ouais.
Bah la taloche, la taloche que vous
attendez, c'est peut-être
un événement exotique extérieur. C'est
comme ça qu'on app une crise financière,
une crise climatique, un petit déluge
histoire de faire
On a eu un tsunami,
ça a rien changé. On a eu une guerre, ça
a rien changé. On a eu une pandémie.
H
ils sont toujours à gérer les stocks de
masque comme des bras cassés.
Ouais.
Là là il y a une résurgence de pandémie
en Chine. Ils ont mis de semaines à
comprendre que bon
fallait peut-être monitorer un peu ce
qui se passe. Ils sont un petit peu
empattés ces gens-là.
Ouais.
He ils sont peut-être dressés à faire
perdurer le rondron quotidien.
Il faut leur insuffler de l'énergie.
Cette énergie française qu'on a en nous.
Ouais. Mais je pense que cette énergie
euh euh cette énergie faut que ce soit
une énergie citoyenne au fond. Voilà, il
faut euh
donc il faut dire arrêter de les banques
centrales, il faut dire directement aux
citoyens. Adressez-vous aux citoyens.
Mais c'est ce que je fais m'adresser
m'adresser aux citoyens c'est pas tant à
Christine Lagarde que j'adresse mes
travaux. Vous l'aimez bien Christine
Lagarde responsable mais pas coupable.
Tout va bien. On va rembourser quand ce
sera venu le temps. C'est ça ?
Ouais. C'est sans doute
c'est sans doute pas la pire et je pense
que c'est pas c'est pas facile
aujourd'hui d'être
d'être une d'être une banquière d'être
une banquière centrale. Mais cela étant
le euh
le je dirais que le le le profil d'une
d'une banquère centrale comme Christine
Lagerde est assez
est assez intéressant parce que ça
montre que pour arriver si vous voulez à
à faire son à faire son chemin, à
exploser les plafonds de verre, il faut
pas
il faut pas vouloir perturber l'ordre
établi, donc
Euh
ça
ça veut dire que
même quand on a même quand on a des
femmes qui qui gouvernent des banques
centrales et bien euh on a des
personnalités qui restent assez
conservatrices quoi.
Question internet.
H
quand vous dites les comptes sont
sécurisés jusqu'à 100 100000 €.
Hm. Je dis pas que les comptes sont
sécurisés jusqu'à 100000 €. Je dis qu'il
y a une garantie des dépôts, d'accord ?
Euh jusqu'à
un peu comme la garantie des assurances,
c'est ça ?
Jusqu'à 100000 €. Bah ça veut dire que
il y a ce fond de garantie des dépôts en
France et il y a des fonds de garantie
des dépôts équivalents si vous voulez.
C'est un dispositif qui est harmonisé
euh au sein de euh au sein de la zone
euro et qui fait que normalement bah si
votre banque fait si votre banque fait
faillite, vous pourrez récupérer jusqu'à
euh 100000 € de 100000 € de dépôt. Bien
sûr que si toutes les banques font
faillite en même temps, ce fond de
garantie des dépôts n'arrivera pas
n'arrivera pas à indemniser à indemniser
tout le monde et ça fonctionnera. Donc
là la fin de la question c'était donc je
je la relis quand vous dites les comptes
sont sécurisés donc passons sur mot
sécurisé jusqu'à 100000 €
qu'est-ce qui empêcherait un
gouvernement de faire passer un 493 ou
un état d'urgence qui supprimerait cette
loi
peut tirer par les cheveux mais c'est
quand même viable hein.
Ouais. Alors euh je pense que c'est une
c'est une question qui pointe euh qui
pointe surtout si vous voulez le le
dysfonctionnement croissant de notre
démocratie quoi. Euh et euh bon après on
peut pas on peut pas tout faire passer
avec du 493 et on peut pas défaire on
peut pas défaire les lois avec
du du 493.
Question internet. Le modèle économique
européen est basé sur de l'énergie pas
chère. Maintenant que le chaos arrive à
cause des vagues de licenciement, que le
fond de garantie des fonds n'est
absolument pas financé, est-ce qu'on
assistera à la fin de la France ?
Euh, pouvez me redire la question ?
Oui, la question est un peu formulée,
c'est un peu alambiqué,
je vais la reformuler.
Et l'économie,
c'est de la transformation énergétique.
Les marchés ne sont qu'un vecteur de
transformation énergétique. On est
d'accord là ? Oui, en tout cas les les
marchés financent ça. Ouais,
effectivement,
on est d'accord, c'est qu'un vecteur.
Bon, maintenant que la base, l'énergie
se rarifie, qu'on a pas encore des
champs d'éolienne,
de panneaux solaires,
d'usine à alg, de paix de vache et on
s'en passe. Donc, on est une un modèle
hyper spécialisé, donc hyper hyper
énergie. H
maintenant que il y a moins d'énergie,
est-ce qu'on va avoir moins
d'économistes qui racontent des
conneries ?
Euh non, mais euh notre notre dépendance
euh
économiste
Ouais. notre dépendance aux économistes
autant que notre dépendance au
aux énergies fossiles. Euh
ça si vous voulez ça explique une bonne
partie évidemment de la de la situation
de la situation actuelle et c'est un euh
c'est je dirais une des euh un des
facteurs importants de euh de
l'inflation du moment. Si on faisait le
lien entre
l'inflation actuelle et euh
euh nos problèmes euh nos problèmes de
dépendance énergétique et le dérèglement
climatique, euh
on apporterait on apporterait de de
meilleurs de meilleurs remèdes. Moi, je
suis persuadé que l'inflation
l'inflation actuelle a beaucoup à voir
avec
l'absence de transition énergétique,
avec l'absence de transition écologique.
C'est pas c'est pas l'avancée dans la
transition écologique qui fait monter
l'inflation. C'est l'absence de
transition écologique qui qui fait
monter l'inflation parce que
on est de plus en plus confronté à des
dérèglements climatiques dont les
manifestations sont de plus en plus sont
de plus en plus claires.
Ça perturbe ça perturbe considérablement
la production la production de matières
premières la production de de matières
premières agricoles. Ça perturbe les
prix agricoles et donc ça explique en
bonne partie si vous voulez le le
la monté de la montée de ces prixlà sur
le plan sur le plan énergétique, le fait
de de ne pas corriger notre
ne pas réduire notre dépendance au aux
énergies fossiles et bien ça aussi ça
participe grandement à l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie et donc tout ça
explique l'inflation. Est-ce qu'on peut
diminuer notre dépendance ? Est-ce qu'on
n pas construit un système financier
qui court tellement vite après sa tête
pour attraper son équilibre tout le
temps ?
H
Est-ce que si on lui diminue son apport,
est-ce que si l'héroïnomane, on le met
un petit peu sous sevrage, il va pas
s'énerver un peu ? On fait une
expérience de pensée, vous et moi,
d'accord ? et la communauté.
On est dirigé par un gouvernement
extraordinaire,
un premier ministre, ministre des
finances, un président de la République,
visionnaire, h
quelqu'un qui voit loin, qui anticipe,
qui est dans l'action. Bon là, on lui
supprime 40 % de son apport en énergie,
genre gaz, gaz naturel, c'est bio, c'est
vert, c'est c'est beau.
Son économie, elle va se vautrer. Bon
là, on passe l'hiver, d'accord ? Comme
il a fait super doux, on va ressortir
avec quoi 30 35 % de nos stock de gaz.
L'hiver prochain, ça va être compliqué
de faire refaire le stock parce que bon,
vous comprenez, on va faire l'embargo
sur les hydrocarbures, les Russie vont
peut-être plus accepter de vendre, le
divorce va se finir de se consommer avec
part fracass.
Notre industrie, elle va se comporter
comment ? Notre marché de l'emploi va se
comporter comment ? Notre inflation va
se comporter comment ?
l'expérience de pensée. Est-ce que vous
pensez que nous français lambda moyen de
la classe moyenne, on va pas s'en
prendre une belle dans la tête avec un
pouvoir politique complètement
déconnecté de la réalité, avec des
une solutionnite du passé ?
H
est-ce que brasser de l'air chaud,
sculpter de la fumée, quand la réalité
vous rattrape, ça risque d'être saignant
?
Ouais, c'est clair. Enfin, si on si on
reste enfermé dans le si on reste
enfermé dans une dans dans la logique
d'hier, dans une logique euh dans une
logique marchande, dans une logique de
de de rentabilité,
on pourra pas s'en sortir. Si si en
revanche bah on fait cette expérience de
pensée là avec un avec un
des gouvernements partout en Europe qui
se coordonne pour
pour réaliser ces transformations. Bien,
dans ce cas, ce sont des gouvernements
qui euh qui investiraient qui
investiraient massivement dans qui
investiraient massivement à la fois dans
la transformation écologique mais dans
la transformation sociale et qui euh euh
pour ça reprendrait les reennes en fait
des reprendrait les reenes des banques
centrales,
les mettrait
les mettrait à leur service mais en
ayant la sagesse en fait de de
d'installer une euh d'installer une
gouvernance suffisamment suffisamment
démocratique et euh euh voilà. Enfin,
moi c'est comme ça si vous voulez que je
me représente le euh ces
transformations,
la réalisation de ces transformations.
Ça vous ça vous convient pas ?
Moi aussi, j'ai envoyé ma lettre Père
Noël cette année.
Non, c'est pas
J'ai j'ai mis un timbre, un vrai.
C'est pas c'est c'est pas c'est pas une
lettre au Père Noël, hein, que de euh
Appelez-le comme vous voulez, hein.
Non, non, mais que de réaliser qu'on a
euh
on dispose des on dispose des
institutions et euh
des institutions qui nous permettraient
de faire ces transformations, mais on ne
les utilise pas comme il faut. On met
pas j'ai des baskets pour courir puis je
cours pas.
Bah ouais,
c'est dommage.
Question internet. A-t-elle déjà
travaillé en entreprise ? Quelles sont
ses expériences professionnelles dans
l'économie réelle ?
Alors euh oui, j'ai déjà travaillé dans
une entreprise, il faut que je vous
raconte mon parcours un peu. C'est
c'est une question pour Omar. Vous
pouvez raconter votre parcours à Omar ou
vous pouvez envoyer chi Omar.
Ouais,
comme vous voulez.
Non, je vais répondre à Omar.
Effectivement, il peut il peut penser
que je suis une universitaire un peu un
peu perchée. Mais euh moi ce qui
m'intéresse si vous voulez c'est
pourquoi rajouter perché ?
Mais parce que vous cessez de me dire là
depuis tout à l'heure que je suis pleine
de de de belles intentions, de de belles
idées, mais que c'est un peu
Je vous donne l'opportunité je vous
donne l'opportunité de répondre à ça.
Si réellement je voulais vous attaquer
sur ça, vous tiendrez
en 10 minutes, je vous plie. On fait le
test.
Bah non, si vous voulez.
Donc pour répondre à Omar, vous avez un
parcours professionnel dans les
activités de et chez qui ?
Ouais. Alors, pour répondre à Omar, donc
euh euh effectivement, moi je suis je
suis quand même un sacré produit
universitaire si vous voulez, mais euh
après euh après ma thèse qui était euh
consacrée à à la réglementation
prudentielle des banques, c'était il y a
longtemps, c'était pas un sujet très
sexy euh à l'époque, c'était bien
avanté.
Ouais. Non, c'était bien avant la crise,
c'était bien avant la crise financière.
c'était, je l'ai soutenu en en 1998,
donc ça euh ça date. Et donc un peu
après ça, j'ai euh j'ai rejoint
l'université
en en en tant que que maîtresse de
conférence. C'est à ce moment-là
l'Encyclopédia Universalisme a qui est
une belle maison m'a m'a demandé si ça
m'intéressait de travailler sur un euh
sur des dossiers qu'ils étaient en train
de de réaliser sur les marchés de
capitaux. Donc j'ai me suis dit que ce
serait intéressant d'aller voir comment
ça euh comment fonctionne comment
fonctionne cette belle entreprise qui
est l'encyclopédia qui était
l'encyclopédia Universalis à l'époque.
Et donc j'ai travaillé pour eux en tant
que conseillère scientifique et j'ai
toujours essayé en fait si vous voulez
d'avoir
je me suis beau je m'investis beaucoup à
l'université mais j'ai toujours essayé
d'avoir un pied dans l'université et un
pied en dehors de l'université. Donc ça
euh ça a commencé euh avec euh cette
activité de de conseil scientifique à
l'encyclopédia Universalis pendant pas
mal d'années, pendant pendant 8 ans.
Après, ce qui m'a intéressé, c'était de
euh de regarder un peu comment se
comment se prenait la décision euh la
décision publique et si euh si
euh si les gouvernements prenaient un
petit peu en compte les
euh les les études des économistes, le
la vie la vie des économistes. Et donc
ça m'a ça m'a amené à travailler en tant
que conseillère scientifique au conseil
d'analyse économique. Donc ça c'était
une activité aussi parallèle à à
l'université. Après, j'ai rejoint un
centre d'étude publique qui s'appelle le
CPI euh qui est euh qui est un centre
d'étude alors qui qui dépend qui est pas
du tout c'est public hein et qui dépend
du qui dépend du
cabinet du Premier ministre qui qui
essaie de à la fois de faire de la
recherche et puis de faire des choses
beaucoup plus grand public de de
diffuser
de diffuser de l'information de
l'information
économique sur des sujets
sur des sujets de commerce
international, sur des sujets de de de
macro financière. Donc, j'ai pas mal euh
pas mal travaillé pour le pour le CPI en
essayant de rendre accessible les les
travaux des économistes du euh les
travaux des des économistes du CPI à
travers leur lettre mensuelle en faisant
un ouvrage en participant en codirigeant
un un ouvrage annuel du CPI qui
s'appelle l'économie mondiale dans
lequel on essaie d'être un peu un peu
un peu prospectif tout en regardant ce
qui s'est ce qui s'est passé en
regardant regardant les grands thèmes
qui sont porteurs pour les années pour
l'année pour l'année à venir. Et puis
après ça, ben j'ai rejoint l'institut
l'Institut VBL. Donc pour répondre à à
Homor, je suis pas euh j'ai pas beaucoup
j'ai pas beaucoup travaillé dans une
entreprise privée, mais j'ai toujours eu
C'est quoi les porteurs là qui arrive
mis à part l'écologie, tout ça ?
les les là, si vous voulez, je pense que
ce qui
ce qui effectivement doit continuer de
mobiliser la la réflexion, c'est la
crise énergétique par exemple, c'est
est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce que cette inflation va être
durable ? Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour en
venir à bout ? Est-ce que au fond est-ce
que on pourrait pas accepter de vivre
avec
pourquoi pas avec un peu plus avec un
peu plus d'inflation si on partage la
valeur autrement ? Enfin voilà, ce sont
des sujets des sujets comme ça qui
peuvent euh qui peuvent nous qui peuvent
nous intéresser. On n pas encore fixé le
programme là de on n pas encore fixé le
sommaire de l'économie mondiale.
Alors un tatane de billet d'avion pour
la Turquie. Oubliez pas.
Question internet. par rapport à son
dernier travail, mettre la
réglementation bancaire au service de la
transition écologique, quelle est son
analyse sur les Green Gate des banques
qui ont menti sur les investissements
verts qui étaient en réalité des actifs
bien gavés en énergie fossile ?
H il faut euh bah on est encore dans
l'AC à Faucon, hein euh
Tatan tatan et billet d'avion pour la
Turquie.
Ouais ouais ouais. Euh
dans ce travail-là sur la euh sur le euh
on va dire sur le verdissement de la
régulation financière, euh ce qu'on
essaie de mettre en en évidence c'est
que euh on est très loin du compte.
D'accord ? Si voilà, ça vous surprend ?
on est c'est-à-dire que on peut pas on
peut pas se contenter des engagements
volontaires des des banques. On peut pas
se contenter de de leur demander
simplement de de communiquer un peu plus
d'informations en matière climatique.
on a besoin en fait de
de transformer, de verdir la régulation
financière et on en a un peu parlé tout
à l'heure, mais pas simplement en disant
au ban qu'il va falloir vous préparer
euh il va falloir vous préparer à euh la
crise climatique comme on leur
demanderait de se euh d'être en mesure
de d'affronter une crise financière. En
fait, je pense que si vous voulez le
parallèle entre crise climatique et
crise financière, il atteint vite ses
limite
parce que
en matière de crise financière, bien sûr
qu'il vaut mieux prévenir que guérir.
Quand on n pas suffisamment prévenu, bah
la crise éclate. Après, faut la gérer et
on la gère assez souvent mal parce queon
prépare celle d'après. Malgré tout, si
vous voulez, bon bah quand on quand
quand la banque centrale et les États
gèrent les crises financières, même si
ça fait même si ça a des répercussions
négatives, au fond, on s'en relève
malgré tout.
La crise écologique, c'est pas ça du
tout, hein. C'estàd que la crise
écologique là dans laquelle on est en
train de de s'enfoncer, elle va procéder
par des seuils en fait
d'irréversibilité. Et puis à un moment
donné et bien on va voilà, on notre
planète sera rendue totalement
totalement inhabitable. Et donc c'est ce
qui me fait dire que ça a pas tellement
de sens de d'essayer de faire évoluer la
la réglementation bancaire simplement en
disant aux banques
préparez-vous à absorber le choc. Ce
qu'il faut c'est précisément
euh faire en sorte que les banques
financent la transformation. Il faut
faire en sorte, si vous voulez que on
ait de moins en moins de dérèglement
Oui, toujours euh on est de moins en
moins de dérèglement climatiqu et donc
euh euh
la le verdissement Non, mais juste pour
finir le raisonnement, euh le
verdissement euh de euh la régulation
financière euh doit euh contribuer à la
réduction du euh
à la réduction du dérèglement
climatique. Et donc trompez pas de de
d'objectif là.
Comment vous
vous trompez pas d'objectif ?
Non. Pour ça les euh
il faut si vous voulez que les je
l'aurais dit beaucoup de fois euh aussi
fa
les le le bilan vraiment le le le bilan
des le bilan des banques doit se
transformer profondément et les banques
doivent financer des activités qui
contribuent à la transition et doivent
se détourner des activités qui
nourrissent le dérèglement climatique.
Et pour ça, il faut des réglementations,
on disait tout à l'heure, des
réglementations qui soient fortes et qui
soient des réglementations
structurelles, pas simplement des
réglementations dites prudentiell. Donc
c'est ça l'idée qui est défendu. Ça
marche pas non plus parce que le
verdissement de la régulation,
c'est beau, c'est c'est
magnifique, c'est c'est limite poétique.
Mais en fait
la la régulation, on a à peu près un
cadre. H
est-ce qu'il faut pas, je vais je vais
revenir encore à mon billet d'avion et
la Turquie, mais est-ce qu'il faut pas
dire tu ne fais pas h
tu iras ?
Ouais. Bah si vous voulez les règles
structurelles, ça revient un peu à ça.
C'estàd que ce sont des règles qui sont
beaucoup plus fortes justement.
Fortes. Il y a des peines de prison à la
à la fin ?
Non, il y a pas des peines de prison.
Est-ce qu'il y a le bagne ? Un bon petit
bagne avec des coups de bâton à
l'ancienne ? Il y a pas ça. Il y a euh
vous aurez une amende de 54,50 € en 2038
quand le process sera passé et encore si
vous mettes vous mettez suffisamment de
temps entre maintenant et le jour du
procès, peut-être qu'on oubliera. Hm.
Est-ce que Est-ce que c'est pas un petit
peu ça qui se passe ?
Non, mais il y aurait des interdictions.
Euh, c'est qu'on en passerait par des
interdictions parce qu'on on n'est pas
du tout dans cette philosophie là
aujourd'hui. C'estd que euh
des interdictions là quand je vois les
actifs bien gavés en énergie fossile,
Ouais. Quand je vois le la manip quand
je vois les manipulations du Libor et de
le Ribor,
quand je vois quand je vois X Y scandale
financier avec euh il y a combien il y a
combien de banquiers en tô ?
Quand je vous dis verdien,
il y a combien de banquiers en tôle ?
Quand je quand je
Il y en a pas beaucoup. Non,
quand je vous dis Verd,
ça vient quoi ? Du prix qui payent leurs
avocats ou ça devient ça vient parce que
ils risquent pas grand-chose.
Non, quand je vous dis verdir la
régulation financière, c'est mettre en
place des règles qui aujourd'hui
n'existent pas. euh mettre en place des
règles euh des règles beaucoup plus
structurelles euh que euh que
prudentielles et ça veut dire euh des
règles qui parviennent à changer la
composition euh du bilan des banques et
donc des règles qui permettraient de
brancher véritablement euh le bilan des
banques sur le financement sur le
financement de la transition, ce qu'on a
pas ce qu'on a pas aujourd'hui. après
votre euh
préconisation.
Non, c'est pas c'est pas la
préconisation, c'est celle que je viens
de c'est celle que je viens de vous
dire, mais
le euh les banquiers sont peut-être pas
complètement à l'abri, hein, si vous
voulez, de euh
d'action d'action en justice qui seront
euh euh qui commencent d'ailleurs à être
qui commencent à être menés et qui
pourront l'être de plus en plus parce
que euh
je pense qu'on on réalise aujourd'hui
que les banques et la finance font
partie du problème, font partie du
dérèglement du dérèglement climatique et
euh à un moment donné elles seront elles
seront traduites en justice. Elles
seront accusées de euh de de participer
à ce de participer
de participer à ce dérèglement. Donc
elles sont pas elles sont finalement pas
complètement à l'abri de ces de ces
actions dont vous dont vous parlez.
Ah moi je me dis je suis banquier,
je p je pèse quoi ? Je pèse 25 millions
de dollars par an. C'est ça ? Un petit
banquier c'est quoi ? C'est 25 millions
de dollars par an.
Un petit banquier ?
Ouais. Aux États-Unis, c'est combien
? Mais vous parlez de quoi là ? bilan de
la banque parce que non je parle moi je
imaginez-vous je suis banquier un petit
banquier classe internationale 25
millions par an je prends
sans les stock option
je me dis bon je vais être traîné en
justice le procès va durer quoi 10 an
j'en ai 70 j'en aurai 80
je vais faire durer le truc parce que je
vais me prendre 4 c avocats en plus ça
va durer 15 ans, j'aurais 85 ans.
Je pourrais plaider que je suis pas
bien, j'ai une cistite, j'ai mal au
rein, j'ai mal au dos, le lit me
convient pas. Donc je serai avec un
bracelet dans ma propriété à Palm Beach.
Tranquille.
Euh
donc
les banquiers vont ou sinon ils vont se
dire "Bon bah c'est mon institution qui
va payer, c'est pas moi."
Ah !
Est-ce que vous pensez pas que les
peines sont
pas assez dissuasives ?
Euh oui, enfin le problème c'est pas le
problème c'est pas le banquier en
lui-même, hein. Le problème c'est euh
c'est les règles qu'on met en place pour
faire fonctionner le pour faire
fonctionner le secteur bancaire. Le
banquier, il est pas plus euh
il est pas plus pas plus opportuniste
que vous et moi, hein. Il est il
fonctionne à l'intérieur d'un cadre. Euh
ouais. Euh il fonctionne à l'intérieur
d'un cadre et l'important c'est ce
cadre. C'est ce cadre qu'il faut
changer.
On va s'occuper de refaire le cadre,
vous inquiétez pas.
Jésabelle, est-ce que vous avez trois
livres ? Alors, est-ce que vous avez
écrit des livres vous ?
Quelques-uns. H
celui qui s'est le mieux vendu, c'était
lequel ?
J'en sais rien. Euh,
s'app comment ? Euh en fait celui qui
s'est le mieux vendu, c'était peut-être
un des euh euh je dirais un des premiers
que j'ai fait. Euh c'était un tout petit
bouquin. C'était un très bon rapport
qualité- prix, je pense. Euh euh c'était
l'économie est un jeu. Euh c'était dans
la collection mais il est il est
complètement je pense qu'il est
complètement épuisé ce petit bouquin.
Mais c'était assez rigolo. C'était assez
euh c'était assez formateur comme
exercice parce que ça prenait la forme
d'un ça prenait la forme d'un quiz. Donc
c'était euh euh c'était euh voilà, c'est
dans la c'était dans la collection
c'était dans la collection Librio.
Après, on en a fait un autre qui
s'appelait euh La finance est un La
finance est un jeu on avait rajouté
dangereux. Euh et euh celui-ci, je crois
qu'il s'est euh il s'est peut-être pas
mal vendu aussi, mais un petit peu euh
un petit peu moins. Après, le
Hop hop hop, ça suffit de
Ah bon ? C'est c'est les plus anciens.
Non, mais il y en a il y en a un dont
dont j'aimerais bien dire un petit euh
un petit mot peut-être.
Plaisir. Et alors deux trois trois tr
Bon, alors euh deux passés et un à
venir. D'accord. Donc euh
parmi euh parmi ceux par Ouais. parmi
les ouvrages que j'ai que j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à faire, il y avait
l'économie pour toutes. Euh et ça
c'était assez euh c'était assez sympa
euh comme ouvrage parce que on est parti
du constat que vous avez un peu hein.
J'ai l'impression que les économistes
sont euh
que les économistes sont extrêmement
jargonneux et en fait
ne me faites pas dire ce que je vous pas
dit. Mais on est parti
parasite inutile cette fois,
on est on est parti du constat que
l'économie c'était un domaine très très
masculin et que le langage de
l'économiste était un langage était un
langage très très masculin, un peu en en
surplomb. Euh
on peut dire de beau si vous voulez.
Bon, je non pas forcément, je vais pas
forcément dire ça comme ça, mais en tout
cas un langage assez assez suffisant et
assez inaccessible. et on s'est dit il
faut il faut voilà il faut il faut
encore une fois il faut changer ce il
faut changer ce ce langage le rendre euh
plus accessible et notamment euh
le avoir une forme un peu plus un peu
plus légère un peu plus féminine. Et ça
ça a donné ça a donné l'économie pour
toutes avec avec Marianne Rubinstein.
Vous l'avez envoyé à Christine Lagarde.
Euh non je crois pas qu'on l' envoyé à
Christine Lagarde. Celui que j'aurais dû
envoyer à Christine Lagarde c'était
plutôt Blabla Banque. Alors, Blabla
Bang, c'était un c'était un essai
un essai qui m'a été inspiré en fait par
une quand j'ai participé à un jury de à
un jury d'agreg du du secondaire où un
des candidats était interrogé sur la
crise de l'état providence et dans son
exposé, il a il a mobilisé un un superbe
ouvrage d'Albert Hirschman. C'est euh de
siècles de rhtorique réactionnaire.
C'est un ouvrage qui date du début des
années 90. Et euh dans cet ouvrage euh
Yerschman explique comment euh les
conservateurs
euh
usent de la de la rhthorique, mobilise
des arguments rhthoriques pour euh
empêcher les pour empêcher les les
réformes euh les les réformes de l'État
de l'État providence. C'est donc ce
qu'explique Hchman dans son dans son
dans son ouvrage, c'est que
finalement à chaque fois qu'on a voulu
du progrès social et bien les
conservateurs usaient soit d'un argument
d'effet pervers en disant le le remède
sera pire que le mal, soit d'un
soit d'un argument de d'inanité en
disant bah ça ne servira à rien, soit de
la mise en péril, ceci va casser cela.
Et puis j'écouté ce candidat qui
présentait hyper bien le travail
d'Hirchman et je me suis dit mais en
fait c'est exactement comme ça que euh
que les banques que le lobby bancaire
réagit au euh réagit au aux réformes aux
réformes bancaires et financières, aux
réformes de la régulation financière.
quand on veut faire avancer la
régulation financière, et bien on a
toujours cette rhthorique qui est
mobilisée par
le secteur bancaire et financier pour
nous dire que bon bah la réforme euh la
réforme elle va avoir un effet pervers.
Si on leur demande plus de fonds
propres, bah ça va ça va casser le
financement euh ça va ça va les rendre
encore plus risqué qu'elle ne l'était
auparavant ou ça va casser le
financement de l'économie. Ça c'est la
mise en péril. ou alors ça servira ou
alors ça servira à rien. Et donc voilà,
ça m'a amené à faire ce à faire ce livre
euh euh blabla banque. J'avais tellement
envie de le faire que je me suis
peut-être un peu un peu précipitée pour
le faire et j'ai pas forcément choisi la
meilleure maison d'édition pour le
faire, mais j'ai adoré faire ce j'ai
adoré faire ce livre. Et bon, après, il
y en a il y en a eu d'autres que j'ai
que j'ai beaucoup aimé mais parmi j'en
ai plus qu'un là, je crois. Non non non
non non. Ben non. Il va y avoir trois
autres bouquins qui ont compté pour vous
dans votre vie.
D'accord.
Mais entre les deux,
il faut augmenter les salaires. Faut que
les salaires ils suivent l'inflation en
ce moment ou pas ?
Euh oui, il me semble si vous voulez
qu'on surestime énormément euh cette
fameuse boucle prix salaire. Bien sûr
qu'on a besoin de de faire en sorte que
les salaires des plus modestes euh
suivent l'inflation pour qu'il soit pas
complètement étranglé par des pouvoirs
par des par des problèmes de de pouvoir
d'achat. Il y a une il y a une
il y a des des des soucis de de
répartition énorme associé à à
l'inflation. C'estàd que les euh
l'inflation fait pas trop de mal aux
riches, elle fait beaucoup plus de mal
au euh aux plus modestes. Donc je pense
qu'on a oui, on a besoin de faire en
sorte que les que les petits salaires
euh suivent l'inflation. Il y a pas de
il y a je pense qu'il y a moins à
craindre de la boucle prix salaire que
de la boucle prix euh profit dans des
économies qui sont euh extrêmement
concentrées avec des entreprises euh qui
ont des gros pouvoirs de marché et qui
peuvent répercuter en fait assez
facilement les la hausse de leur coût de
production sur
le sur le sur le consommateur et
se se garder des marges confortables.
Donc moi, je suis pas du tout
défavorable à la à l'indexation des bas
salaires sur l'inflation.
Trois bouquins qui ont compté pour vous
h
qui ont été formateurs dans votre vie
ou qui vous ont secoué ? Hm. Alors, ben
je crois que le vraiment le le livre
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure là,
celui de celui d'Albert Hchman, euh ça
ça a été quand même une euh ça a été une
sacrée euh rappelez-moi le titre,
deux siècles de rhtorique réactionnaire.
Ça c'est un un super livre de euh
un super livre de d'Albert Hirchman.
Euh après, moi je suis assez euh
euh je suis assez fan de Galbress. Euh
euh
c'est un parce que c'est euh
je trouve que c'est euh euh c'est un
économiste qui euh qui était à la fois
euh euh
je dirais dans le qui était dans une
dans une économie assez euh dans une
réflexion économique assez euh assez
normative qui avait euh qui avait à cœur
de produire des
des recommandations qui était assez euh
assez indépendant d'esprit, qui a été un
peu conseiller du prince. Il me moi
fondamentalement, il me semble que le
l'économiste devrait euh euh
devrait servir à éclairer la à éclairer
la décision publique. Et je pense que
les économistes aujourd'hui se prennent
un petit peu trop pour des
euh
des
savants découvreurs de découvreurs de
loi de lois économique immuable. Ils
sont persuadés en fait.
euh faire de la science comme on ferait
de la de la science physique. Je pense
qu'on est on est plutôt dans l'analyse
de
fonctionnement, de dysfonctionnement et
euh
euh ce qui doit nous amener ensuite à
des euh
à des prescriptions, à une analyse un
peu un peu plus normative. Donc j'aime
bien cet aspect-là chez euh j'aime bien
cet aspect-là chez chez Galbres et
j'aime bien notamment sa brève histoire
de de l'euphorie financière. Ça c'est un
livre qui euh c'est un livre qui m'a euh
c'est un livre qui m'a marqué. Euh
après euh
on a le droit d'avoir des des livres de
KPDP de de
de gladiateur hein si vous voulez
même du Marcel Pagnol, on a le droit
hein.
Euh
euh
je sais pas, il y a trop de
Qu'est-ce que vous lisez en ce moment ?
Alors, en ce moment, je suis plus dans
le je suis plus dans l'écriture dans
l'écriture que dans la que dans la
lecture. Et je me dis que
voilà, ce sont des phases sont des
phases dont il faut se méfier, ça
parfois, voyez, où on est on est plus
dans euh où on écrit, on écrit, on écrit
et puis on on ne lit plus euh on ne lit
plus on ne lit plus suffisamment. Alors,
cela étant, j'ai j'ai ma pile he moi
aussi sur euh j'ai ma pile à lire, ma
pile de livre en retard sur
mon chevé. J'ai commencé j'ai commencé
mon cher connard, mais j'ai pas
C'est de qui ? de Virginie des Pentes.
C'est pas une économiste mais parfois
elle a des elle a des petites réflexions
économiques qui sont qui sont
intéressantes. Euh mais voilà, j'ai pas
j'ai pas pris le temps j'ai pas pris le
temps d'avancer davantage.
Déjà c'est pas mal hein. Est-ce que vous
avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ? Une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose d'impérissable, quelque
chose qui sera écouté
par nos jeunes ? En fait, je pense qu'on
a besoin euh de réfléchir à bah ce dont
on a besoin. Voilà, on a on a besoin de
réfléchir à à ce qui nous est vraiment
utile, de quoi on a vraiment besoin
aujourd'hui. On en on on
doit complètement repenser notre euh
notre notre bien-être et se demander
comment est-ce qu'on peut euh euh
comment est-ce qu'on peut rendre ce euh
ce bien-être compatible. avec euh
avec les limites planétaires, avec le
respect de de l'humain, il faut qu'on
s'interroge euh
sur nos besoins euh et sur notre
bien-être. Je suis voilà, il faut une
réflexion collective sur le sur le
bien-être pour un effort de
pour un effort de sobriété.
Jésabelle Coupé Sousant, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]